welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice ramsey personality dr
john deloney
is my co-host today here on the air
we're taking your calls about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two
five john we don't spend much time on
this show
talking about politics uh oh um
because i'm a firm believer that
you control more of your life than they
do correct
and yet we're you and i are you're have
a doctorate in counseling
and you and i were discussing that we
are seeing a new syndrome in the mental
health field
pop up the post-election deranged
disorder
and it manifests itself in one of two
ways depending on who you voted for or
you deeply believed in
if you voted for and deeply believed in
donald trump you are
irrationally depressed and think that
the world is coming to an end several of
my friends are
contemplating you know where they're
going to live
other than the united states i mean they
just have lost their dadgum minds
and then if you voted for biden and
we're deeply invested in that
emotionally you have the
post-election deranged disorder and are
irrationally exuberant
as if you're gonna get a car that's
right like oprah got elected you get a
car and
you get a car and you get a car no loans
for anybody
yeah yeah we're just gonna we're gonna
just completely it's it's communism now
and and we're all gonna be entitled now
guess what they're both wrong
this is a mental disorder yes there's a
third one
and those are the folks just uh
collecting coffee and bullets
as because they think that the currency
is gonna be that's gonna be the new
currency right
we're just gonna trade coffee and
bullets for food we're gonna eat our
pets
which if that's the case tennessee's in
pretty good shape we're gonna be in
great shape tennessee and texas and and
arkansas that's gonna be the no
the no-go zone right yeah yeah well for
certain yeah oh my gosh
yeah yeah and really all joking aside
but not really joking
some of you and some of you that would
fall within the circle of my personal
influence as well as
the influence from this show need to get
a life
you are not dependent upon washington
d.c
if you are a liberal and you think that
the washington dc is going to solve
america's problems you are stupid if you
are conservative and you think that
washington dc is going to solve
america's problems you are
stupid and if you think it's going to
fix your life
you're stupid i'm 60 years old i've been
working for 40 plus
years earning money paying income tax
and none of these people have sent me
money
there's been quasi-socialists and people
that were conservative just to the right
of genghis khan in the white house
during these times
and none of them fixed my life or run
my life just kept it plugging along huh
well i mean yours too yeah you know your
mama and daddy my mama and daddy i mean
it's guys what happens at your house is
more important than what
what happens at the white house
why is that so hard for people to wrap
their head around we look
we want the long ranger to come and
rescue us
we want to we want this to get easy
someday that's what it is this grown-up
thing is going to get easy someday and
somebody else is going to do the work
for us
and someone else is going to do the
sacrifice for us and we can be little
children again
we all want that that life has this
hidden
lottery thinking i'm going to get
discovered it's not going to happen the
colonel parker's going to come along and
i'm going to be elvis
that this whole radio and publishing
thing and
this whole uh being in the media thing
is gonna get easy all of a sudden right
that i'm not gonna have to deal
with crooked people right
that i'm not gonna have to deal with
people who betray you and talk about you
behind your back who said they were your
friends
i keep thinking this is going to get
easy welcome to grown-up land boys and
girls
it gets harder harder and harder there's
a great theologian
um named rich mullins who said the worst
part about being a christian is that
it's every single day
and you could never memorize all the
books of abraham to where
you never had to do anything else right
and i've you can't finish
right and i've rattled that around in my
head that works for exercising i can
never have such a good workout on a on a
monday
that you don't have to do that i'm done
for the rest of the month right that's
it donuts yeah i'm just gonna
i don't have to i did this good workout
on monday so i need a box of donuts
every morning the rest of the week and
i'll think about it doing another one in
december right
and it's the same with your money it's
the same with your marriage you wake up
every day and decide i'm gonna love her
no matter what yep in spite of myself
and i'm gonna default to these things
that i know i'm gonna let these children
live another day
well i don't know man i got a four and a
half year old she is pushing on me dave
oh man um you know there you you
you part of being a grown-up is nobody's
gonna do it for you
and it's every day it's every day it's
every day make your bed
wave to your neighbor every day make
your bed
yeah do your stuff man be kind every day
and guess what
you know you being a troll on twitter is
not going to make your life better
no one has ever been convinced to vote
politically or to become
or to meet jesus by someone being mean
to them never
it's never happened no one has ever
yelled and cussed and screamed at me and
convinced me to do anything
that's right ever ever right in my whole
stinking ball-headed life it has never
happened no
you know and so stop it stop stop it
be a grown-up what happens at your house
which is what we teach you around here
we help you with you
right and you're the solution to your
problem
and you're the problem to your problem
just like i am at my house and you are
at your house john
so the post-arranged post-election
deranged
disorder is real uh
and it has to do if you placed your hope
on the wrong things which will always
cause your hope to dissipate
because guess what if you place your
hope on that preacher he's going to let
you down
100 people he's a man that's right he's
going to screw up something
go say something you don't like someday
you place your hope on that boss these
people come to work here
they got stars in their eyes they think
dave ramsey's the second coming it takes
him about 20 seconds to figure out
that's not right
it didn't take me that long but i got
what you're saying i get what you're
saying right
thank you you're saying three two one
okay
that's right but yeah and
it's this at some point folks have to go
look in the mirror and say
i've got to be responsible yes there is
hard stuff yes there's a ton of things
we've got to do together
but you can't control the things
anything starts with me looking in the
mirror and saying
i'm going to choose it's irrational
exuberance and it's irrational
depression it really is
irrational right because it means you
place your hope on something that is not
logical
that is not going to work it's not going
to work
it never has so give people one or two
things
tell me a time that washington dc fixed
your life
and i'll shut up about it you know i
can't think of one i mean
it doesn't freaking exist and yet people
are running around
hooting and hollering and honking their
horns like biden's gonna send them a car
and my conservative friends are just
like they really do they
some of them really are buying coffee
and bullets i mean oh my gosh
and gold bars another stupid crap in
this morning when i got to work here
someone had put a note in my box
that made my whole day start off right
what did i say they just said thanks for
being you and thanks for some stuff i
had done
but i'm telling you oh it was not
looking for somebody else to solve a
problem somebody wrote me a note it's
that easy
to be about changing your community in
your neighborhood in your home be nice
be kind there's a good start
don't place your hope on the wrong
things dr john deloney
my co-host today this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
hi i'm mary and i'm from conroe texas
just north of houston
the only thing that i remember my dad
saying
about money charge it that way you don't
have to pay for it
fast forward a number of years and i've
got a young son
and i became one of those women you
can't trust with a credit card
and i thought that i was doing okay with
my money as long as i was making these
small purchases
but i realized later i was making
a lot of those little purchases and then
somewhere along the way somebody told me
about dave ramsey
and i remembered hearing you tell
somebody once that
they had a an income problem and that
was me over 35
of my take-home pay was going towards
debt payment
so i was going along trying to get baby
step one done and i knew it was going to
be months before i could even get
two three hundred dollars saved up so i
gave up and i went straight to baby step
two
and maybe that's part of being single
not having somebody else to bounce this
off of
i just didn't think that i could do it i
actually had no hope that i could ever
do this
well you do have to have reinforcements
you have to have some kind of people
around you telling you you're not crazy
in a world that's crazy the turning
point for me though
finally came when i became eligible for
retirement
i finally decided this is it this is
where i draw the line in the sand
[Music]
well after 20 years working with the
state i
went to work for blinds.com in my
case my change of job meant that instead
of driving 10 miles down the road
to work i was driving 50 miles down the
road
i didn't have a clue what was going on
in fact i found myself sometimes i would
cry
all the way to work and then i'd have to
be all
nice and happy and everything at work
and pay attention to what i was doing
and i would cry all the way home
that was really tough that was really
seriously tough
but i made it through i've been sharing
at work
that i was going through this journey
and one of the ladies had been through
fpu
so she loaned me her cds to listen to
and
once i was listening to those i knew
that i had to do
fbu but i waited for
a few to go on sale on the site the home
study course
and i got that they flesh everything out
in such an amazing way
that i just kept thinking i wish i had
done this
a long time ago and it
really reframes the way you look at
things
in my world it turned me completely
upside down
[Music]
call my show all the time complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people
out of their timeshares we have we kind
of helped create this industry
now there's a lot of exit companies out
there they come and they go
timeshare actually team is different i
mean we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
our guarantee is that if we can't get
you out of your timeshare we give you
your money back
hey if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshare timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
author of the new quick read
that is now out officially entitled
anxiety redefining anxiety
oh that yeah taking a different look
different kind of anxiety if you
get the title wrong that's right that's
exactly right no i'm excited about it
man it's um
it's a quick laser beam of a little book
that um
gets right to the point man talking
about well these quick reads are like a
chapter two chapter books so it's like
30 40 pages right
well this is about 80 pages it gets
right to the point if you got two phds
this big chapter they let me go a little
bit long yeah we did have some
negotiations on how long i can
keep running my mouth right a little bit
yeah but it is about um changing the way
we
we think of anxiety that it's a death
sentence and it's forever and it doesn't
have to be
yeah check it out at daveramsey.com
we'll get a copy of it in here and show
you guys on youtube in a few minutes oh
there they go they pop it up they're
like
already know what we're doing and
everything amy's with us in albany new
york hi amy welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi how are you great how can we help
well my husband and i have been together
for about 13 years
married for about 10. um i
am the
responsible financial part of our
marriage
um and i lost my job due to covid
uh so i've been kind of feeling
you know talking referencing anxiety
i've been feeling super
anxious you know regarding kind of
losing my job
um and our finances um he is like i said
the polar opposite of me
and i'm this has been a elephant in the
room
so to speak for our whole marriage and
i'm just trying to figure out how to get
him on the same page as me
what's he do for a living um he works
for uh municipality
doing what um he's like a
commercial building inspector oh
okay all right cool does he share that
you are also the responsible one
or does he think he is a responsible one
and he just lets you have some
at least to run no he he shares that i'm
the responsible one
and i i think kind of sometimes takes
advantage of that
okay all right well there's a whole
bunch of things going on here
uh that that uh
the reason i ask what i did for a living
is i'm trying to figure out how to
connect to him
and uh speak to him in a way that allows
him to hear it okay
when he's a building inspector and he
goes in and inspects a building if they
haven't followed the formula
to properly build the building the
stupid thing will fall in and it's his
job to throw a red flag right
you guys are following a formula that
has a very very very low statistical
probability
of winning with wealth building
and of having a high quality marriage
correct so the the millionaire study
that we did for chris hogan's book
almost all the 10 000 millionaires that
were married the vast majority of them
had a spouse that worked as their
partner and they worked together towards
common goals
and so they had shared finances they
were not roommates
okay so statistically if you want to be
a millionaire
you're doing it wrong okay that's kind
of what we're saying right if you just
want to say look at the da
the data what's the data say this is how
you do it and so that that's a
from a practical guy's standpoint that's
me i i'm looking at it that way now
relationally what
we have found actually occurs when you
share
everything which is what the wedding
vows say
uh for sickness and health for richer
for poor and the old ones in the comic
book of common prayers say and unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
isn't that a pretty old english kind of
feel
unto thee all my worldly goods i pledge
in other words
i'm yours you're mine we're doing this
together period not
hey you lost your job i hope you worked
that out
it's a little different and so getting
on the same page and when you can agree
on your spending you're agreeing on your
goals you're agreeing on your fears
you're carrying burdens together
and you're having celebrations together
versus high-fiving your roommate who
just got a raise
right what is that what does that
conversation sound like when you say
let's let's combine this what is his
reasoning um
so we have we tried that when we were
first married and like i said i'm
usually the very responsible one
um and quickly realized that he
could not be reeled in with um
you know spending uh you're not his mom
yeah you're not his mom
all right yeah correct but
again what is the conversation like when
you if you were to sit down tonight and
say hey
i want to revisit this let's let's join
let's
get one account what would his rebuttal
be
um i think he would be okay with that
because of
my financial stability i guess where my
concern
is is knowing that
even though i've lost my my job
currently i was in a pretty good
financial position
you know with the balance of my mortgage
my savings account
my retirement account um i think he
would be okay with that because he may
have access
then to what i have kind of saved and
earned
but you don't you're not okay with it
no i'm not especially knowing that
um okay so part of part of you joining
it together means that we are both
grown-ups
and we are both setting goals and we're
both agreeing on
how we're going to do all our money he
gets
a vote you get a vote we write it down
called a budget and we pinky swear and
spit shake that we're gonna stick to the
contract
and then if he goes off the rails and
goes and buys something that is not on
that big
some big item comes on with a two
thousand dollar item and says oh look
what i did uh
he's broken the contract he's lied
and that has to be the new terms of this
deal and it sounds like you have a
i may miss something here it sounds like
you have a pronoun problem
you keep saying the money that you saved
and that you paid down
how long have you all been married 10
years 10 years yeah
i this may be a hymn problem right now
but it sounds like it's a you problem
it sounds like you are reticent to
receive him into this
into this new like dave said this new
contract well he has to be willing to
commit to the contract and that would
get rid of her
her problems with this but then you
can't you can't nickel and dime him on
the contract that's not what i'm talking
about but you say
hey we are going to lay out a budget we
both have input on it we both have a
vote
and then we are both agreeing to be
grown-ups and stick to it i ain't your
mama
sure she lives in pakistan yeah and
usually that begins with the values with
the destination
conversation where are you headed yeah
what are you going to do where do we
want to go together
not i want to have this house paid off
in 10 years but where are we going to be
right and he's got to be a part of the
values of a part of the journey
conversation
not a part about the did you follow up
my rule conversation
here's what's interesting with anyone
married couples or otherwise
if you say i've got a group of leaders
here inside my company
when we can agree on where the money's
going to go
and what the goal is with the money we
create a
different level of spiritual
and emotional unity unity that's right
unity because you're communicating
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is and when you can agree
on that you're combining hearts
and so i you know i don't dictate to our
team what the budget is they turn in a
budget on one of the profit centers and
vice president publishing preston that
just did this book with you he's going
to turn in a
publishing budget that includes what
he's going to make on redefining anxiety
and what it costs and those kinds of
things and then i'll look at that with
him and he and i may have a discussion
and make some adjustments
or his svp or his esvp or whatever it
would have that discussion and i might
get involved
but when we have finally come to
agreement on what we think we're going
to make and what we think we're going to
spend and the profit we're going to have
as a result in that business unit we
have now joined hearts
and you know what she she she she said
something that i want to make sure
everybody hears
she said and i think he's going to think
this
we have got to get out of other people's
heads we have to
we've got to look at they're strenuous i
know but we've got to look at their
strenuous to be in their heads it's
exhausting it takes a lot of energy
right you're almost always wrong when
you get in somebody else's head decide
why they're about to do something that
he hadn't even done it yet right um join
as one
get on the same page with where you're
gonna be join hearts join finances
and get out of each other's heads man
yeah one checkbook
one budget one goal one set of goals one
set of fears
that are shared and man when you do that
no stopping ding ding ding it goes
your probability of high quality
marriage your probability
of wealth building goes way up and your
probability of it not being either
otherwise
way down you have a roommate
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because i'm single one of the things is
that
i'm a very very free spirit i think
as far as spending so i had to kind of
depend
on my budget
every dollar really made that much
easier for me because it
it has more to it than i ever would have
thought to put on a spreadsheet
every dollar kind of helped to be my
partner
but i have just really really enjoyed
knowing about money for the first time
in my life
knowing what a real budget is
and knowing that i have a future
you can wish to be out of debt but
wishing isn't going to make it so
you can even dream about it
but the the thing is that when that
dream turns into
a specific goal and a specific time and
you have a plan to work that
that even when you're single having that
plan
will help you know where to go and how
to get there
if you have waited this long to start my
word to you
is it is never too late you're not alone
there are other people doing this
all over the country i have done it i'm
living proof
you can do it to me the biggest thing
was
was getting hope finding that hope that
i could really do this
i'm here to tell you the hope is there
do what it takes
start start now today
three two one i'm
dead
my son and granddaughter and i came back
from my
dream vacation at walt disney world
it's been a dream of mine since he was a
young child to take him there
it was such an emotional thing for me i
just
i cried i cried at the end when they had
the fireworks
it wasn't about the extravaganza it was
about
standing there with my son and my
granddaughter
and we had done this to have that
experience
it really has made me learn
that dreams when they're turned in to
goals
really do come true
[Music]
hey guys by now you know about financial
peace university
this is the class that teaches you the
proven plan to take control of your
money
get out of debt and build wealth over
six million people
have done this and on the front lines
are these people called coordinators
that are leading these classes
all across the country they invest their
time to help other people like you
win with money and you can be one of
them but we reached out to them to
figure out
why they do this thing in the first
place here's what they had to say
the reason that i teach fpu is because
dave's plan really works
so it's really laid out well and just
anybody can do it
i felt called to lead the class at our
church and
i continue to lead because of the change
that i'm seeing in our church
community from the very first day people
were open and honest and
we're going gazelle intense already from
the beginning the participants
seeing the changes they make from week
one to week nine
is so rewarding the best part about it
is seeing people actually come out
say for the future and best of all have
hope i can't wait to lead more classes
i can't wait to see more lives get
changed it is such a rewarding
experience
that was awesome listen if you want to
make an impact and help others win with
money
you can lead a financial peace
university class which is now a part
of ramsay plus you don't have to have
gone through the class before
you don't have to be debt free and you
don't have to be a financial expert
you just have to have a heart to serve
others and a commitment to what we teach
our team does all the teaching and we
make it super easy
and fun to lead plus you can lead a
class from anywhere
oh and coordinators get some sweet perks
for leading too
to get started just text the word life
changer to 33789
and we'll send you a link with all the
info you need to help others find
financial peace
again that's life changer all one word
to 33789
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage eric and tiffany are with us
hey guys how are you
good how are you guys better than we
deserve debt free way to go
thanks how much you pay off uh 59
165 very good how long did this take
about 17 months
good for you and your range of income
during between 80 and 100 000.
cool what do you guys do for a living
i'm an electrician for denier electric
and i am actually a surety account
manager so i issue bonds
oh very cool good for you guys so what
kind of debt was the 59
000 we had a credit card debt two
vehicles personal loans
kind of like normal yeah very how long
you all been married
eight years okay that's about how long
it takes to get that normal yes
so credit card two car loans personal
loans
just a little bit of everything pretty
much yeah so you're kind of bopping
along just living the american dream
not and uh what happened 17 months ago
they got all this started
well um i would say from probably the
beginning of our marriage it felt like
a lot of things weren't really within
our control and
so um pretty early on in our marriage
for
the first couple of years we were
actually um going through fertility
treatment
and so that didn't work and we
decided to take a next step and um we
decided to be from foster parents
and um
there was some ups and downs lots of ups
and downs and
it financially kind of hit us as well
yeah we didn't make
a lot of best decisions when we were
doing that and um
just because it was really emotional
yeah it was hard tone of emotion
yeah um but we um did ended up adopting
our youngest son max
in 2017 and that's when
we decided to
we well we were hoping to jump on the
dave ramsey
financial peace university and
we at the time um
are my stepson who's cameron um
something really hard happened to him
too so again another hard thing that
really wasn't in our control and
we had to file emergency custody for him
and so at that time it just kept getting
we kept feeling we were getting more and
more in whole we actually had to pay it
off car at the time
that we had to sell um to pay lawyer
bills and we had
um we were selling everything and there
came a point where we were looking at
each other and we were like i think we
might have to sell our house
money from our parents we had to borrow
money from our parents we sold
everything we could and
um it was just really it was a really
tough hard
time and so as soon as that ended um
we you know picked up financial peace
university
we started reading um total money
makeover and um
january of 2019 we we were like
that's it we can't go through this again
we can't there can't be another
situation that
something happens to us that we don't
have any control
we've got to have some margin we could
have some margin when life happens yeah
this being out of control things scary
yeah i hear you i know exactly how you
feel
that's what grown-ups do way to go yeah
i mean you go we're going to get the
we're going to control the controllables
so that when the uncontrollables come
then we at least have this much margin
to absorb the blows when the big bad
wolf comes if we build out a brick then
we get to be the third pig
right exactly so there we go hey way to
go guys
very cool so you went to financial peace
university and dove in but you and you
were both like
over it you're ready to go right more
than ready yeah
yeah definitely okay it was really hard
i don't hear a lot of
dads a lot of husbands use a word you
just used you said it was scary
tell me about that so it's kind of like
financially terrifying as well as
emotionally so with the emotion you
obviously want to spend more money
so there was some disagreements and i
think we worked through it pretty well
it took a while but um did you ever have
a night where she was asleep and
foster kid's asleep and you're just
pacing around the house
trying to figure it out like every night
yeah
eight nights it was actually more her um
i was more nervous and
and about what was going to happen in
court but also like
how am i going to provide for my family
and so you guys get into this you're
rocking and rolling and then the world
shuts down
oh yeah yeah of course yep life happens
tell me what
tell me what you guys decided then so we
actually
we kind of hoarded money for a little
while um and um
so we i was home since march i've been
working at home since march
and um so we kind of paused our debt
snowball
and when we realized that neither of us
because the city was we live in
cincinnati i was starting to shut down a
little bit and he
is the downtown foreman for his
electrical company and so we were like
i'm not sure if
he neither of us are going to be able to
go to work and what's going to happen so
we actually
um we ordered it for a little while oh
much more piled it up and had to write a
20 000
check to pay off the truck whoa it felt
good that felt good though it felt
amazing but it was
it was also scary do you really want
this truck yeah so
yeah i don't like this truck that much i
thought about selling it
because we just went through the whole
custody thing yeah
it was yeah it was hard now that you're
the other side of all of this
and you've got that margin and you did
it you climbed the mountain how's it
feel
amazing yeah it feels really great we
actually have finished
baby step three now too
very cool that that is cool feels good
now you've gone you've gone through the
class what do you tell people the steps
are
to getting out of debt because i mean
you you were i mean you had everything
coming at you pandemics custody battles
you had everything coming at you
and you still you know draw your sword
fight through the thicket and
what do you tell people the key is i
would say sticking to a plan
making a budget and sticking to it is
even when you don't want to if you want
to go
buy something or not cook at home that
night i think
making a plan together staying on the
same page is definitely
a huge key factor how has this helped
your marriage
oh we couldn't be more closer um yeah
yeah i'm very good
take frequent date nights now um we have
the money for the babysitter
and it feels awesome so it's great yeah
that's cool
very very cool i guess it's the first
time you've been debt-free in eight
years of marriage right yes
yeah very good so who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
so your parents my parents definitely
our kids
so your parents uh knew that you were
doing all this then yeah
they helped us out a lot they helped us
through the custody custody
the fostering oh that's right you said
you borrowed money from them that you
had to pay back yeah
it did in fact they actually tried to
just give it to us but we didn't
feel comfortable with that yeah wow they
were your cheerleaders because they were
like hey look
this will get us off the hook from being
the bank too right
they were like cheering you guys on man
but yeah we want you to be debt-free
yes they do we actually had something
pop up on the house recently and we i
was talking to my dad and i was like
it's gonna cost us like four thousand
dollars he's like well
do you want some money and i was like we
don't need your money yeah we don't need
you
yes that was fantastic that's a
different kind of dignity there
yeah well done guys we're so proud of
you guys
very well done you brought the young men
with you what are their names and ages
uh cameron he is 12 and maxwell he's
seven
all right thank you very fun
what a great great story very cool eric
tiffany cam and may
from cincinnati 59 000 paid off we've
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires that's the next
chapter in your story then you'll have
the margin to not only
uh control the controllables but help
other people do that
you know if you live like no one else
later you can live and give
like no one else all right 59 000
paid off in 17 months making 80 to 100
000
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
ready three two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
yeah baby that's how it's done
you got a couple here who's already
about changing legacies right they've
foster kids step kids they are have an
open heart and open home
and sometimes when we try to give with
money we don't have
we end up weighing ourselves we we drag
ourselves under water unintentionally
right
and now they've flipped it around and
they are not only changing hearts and
legacies
but man now they're planting trees for
those two boys that those
two boys are going to eat from fruit
those guys are never going to see but
what an incredible incredible gift
you've given them absolutely
absolutely on so many fronts on so many
fronts
beautifully done well done you guys
we're very proud of you you're heroes
and real real heroes man
amazing this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys i'm george camel host of the
dave ramsey show video channel
you know every day people from around
the country come to our lobby
to do their debt-free scream on air and
we celebrate that so much because we
know
what freedom from debt can actually mean
it means that people are free to do
amazing things
and live like no one else like jet ski
the great loop
or start a dream business or retire
early and travel the country in an rv
or maybe it's simply giving more of
their money or their time through
volunteer work
or ministry so here's the deal if you're
doing something entirely outrageous and
out of the box
and it's all because you're debt free we
want to hear from you
sharing your stories can encourage other
people who are making their way
along those baby steps just send an
email to daveonair
daveramsey.com with the subject line
live like no one else and let us know
what life looks like for you now
we can't wait to hear your stories
[Music]
it's easy for us to all get bogged down
into finances
and that can really hinder your work
performance if you have something going
on in your personal life
i just remember this feeling of hoping
i'm gonna make it
until my next payday am i going to get
the electric bill paid our grocery money
is gone
retiring and planning for the future was
nerve-racking what's going to happen
when there's just no money there's
nothing there
so as we look at trying to create a
culture where employees can be
successful
being able to reduce that anxiety and
take control of their lives
is important and that's where the smart
dollar program really plays a critical
role for us
it's a teaching tool you're giving them
a lifelong skill set
whether it's getting out of debt or
budgeting or how to best prepare for
your future
there was something in there for
everyone i was really surprised by how
quickly i was able to start tackling my
goals
it makes work easier because i know i'm
working towards something i paid off
over 20 000 in debt this year i paid off
all of my student loans
expect to be out of debt by this year we
don't have arguments
the way we did before smart dollar
brought me and my wife together
now we can retire over dignity the
stress of carrying that financial burden
is gone
we have truly changed our family tree
teaching someone how to be financially
responsible
shapes your entire life
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there plus they
offer unbelievable financial benefits
secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour open phones at triple
eight
eight two five two as we take your
questions about your life
and your money boston is with us in
charleston that sounds confusing hey
boston what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help
so i recently just graduated college in
may 2020
i'm 22 years old and i was really
fortunate my dad had the 911 gi bill
so my first three years of college were
absolutely free or paid for out of
pocket
by my parents wow wonderful yeah i'm
extremely lucky
what's your degree my dad always
promised me that he would pay for my
college tuition
and that last year we had to take out 40
grand for my last out-of-state year
i took it out in my name under my credit
score
because my dad had a worse credit score
than me
so it's technically out under my name
and my dad
has sorry get a little nervous my dad
has
automated monthly payments so he is
paying it off
but should i just also pay that off
because it's under my name
or should i take this blessing and i
have no other debt
and should i start like snowballed
investing
what's your degree in computer science
okay and how much you're making 70 000 a
year
okay good for you well done thank you so
much
um
uh your dad is a great guy and i'm
really thankful for his
um service
and how that afforded you the first
three years of school
uh for free and i'm also thankful for
his willingness to do the other things
however he has no money
right i mean no no is that is that a
correct statement he has no money
no that's incorrect he makes nearly a
quarter million a year
he makes a quarter of a million a year
yes his military pension is eighty
percent why is he broke
i mean he got a divorce three years ago
we
moved every two years sometimes he
purchased houses and thought they were
good
and you still live with your dad no i
just graduated college so there's no we
my mom so there's no we we used to
now they but if he makes 250 000 a year
i would ask him to if he wants to
honor this process i would ask him to
pay it off this year
not over 20 years
because it leaves you vulnerable
yes it does i mean i mean i am preparing
in the instance that i have to take over
it it doesn't
seem like that day will come because now
listen that's not
that's not the point if he's not going
to pay it off in six to 12 months
which he should do my god boston
something's
something's in your soul about this deal
why why are you even asking this
question
do you not feel right taking the money
now
no um it's not that i wouldn't accept it
i'm just
curious if now that it falls under my
name and i know we don't care about
credit scores here
but yeah you know i care about i care
about you
having a student loan debt of forty
thousand dollars your dad doesn't have
any debt
and you do you're not asking a math
problem you're asking a character for
a question
yeah i just wish it would be paid off
sooner amen
so if he's not going to pay it off in
six to 12 months after you have this
discussion with him tonight
then you should
okay and
my retirement uh ten percent
contribution my rock contribution yeah
okay yeah you you're in baby step two
dude you have forty thousand dollars in
debt
yeah with your name on it right yeah and
it's going to be an uncomfortable
conversation and it's going to be a
grown-up conversation and you're
you're because your dad's dad you're
making 250 000 if you can take care of
this within six to 12 months
fine if you can't i'm gonna knock it out
okay or i say i should say won't
not can't because he can yeah
if you want i don't want this hanging
over my head it's in my name
i've become increasingly uncomfortable
with that dad and so
i i get it if something else is going on
but
i'm just going to tell you if you won't
knock it out with your 250 000 income in
six to 12 months
then i'm going to because i don't want
this over my head
yeah that's that makes sense that's not
disrespectful
it's not mean you're not wagging a
finger at him you're not throwing guilt
trips around
you're not calling up and going you
should really do this because you said
you would you're not doing any of that
you're just gonna go dad you make plenty
of money i know what your income is
and i know you've been through some hard
times in the past but here we are today
i am feeling stressed and uncomfortable
this weight of forty thousand dollars
across the top of my trapezoids and i
can feel it on my back
and i if you won't get rid of it in six
to 12 months i'm going to
and if he says no just go do it go do it
and don't hold him accountable don't
give him the side eye at christmas yeah
just forget it he had a plan
you're choosing to accelerate that plan
which i think is the right thing to do
yeah and then go do it and here here
for future reference okay uh and this
will help you with uh
with other conversations that will come
up another time that because i've had to
learn this the hard way
is that um good people with good
intentions
who handle money poorly never
have any money and therefore always put
themselves in a position to not keep
their words
and it's weird but i mean like like i
know this guy he's a good man
and just let him move in your rental
house and he'll pay the rent no he won't
because he's never paid rent on time in
his freaking life you know so why am i
gonna
all of a sudden reinvent this guy in my
mind just because
he's a good guy you know and the weird
thing is he can actually be a good guy
but suck at handling money
right i was that guy i was talking i was
a good guy but i sucked at it
you know and therefore it left me not
being a good guy sometimes you know
because i couldn't keep my word because
i didn't have enough money to keep my
word and i know people who make 250
grand a year
who run out of money before the month is
over every single month
i mean put any number up there i can
find somebody who spends more than they
make i mean they all
i just act like they live in congress or
something i mean my god
so just spend it like it's water but you
know and it's out of control
disorganized chaotic
and so the point is don't th the lesson
to be learned
for you in the future sir and for all of
us in the future is
if there's a pattern in someone's life
and
you ignore that and and ask them and
accept their promise
then that's on you right and when you
sign your name to it
assume you're paying it back yeah assume
you're paying it back
and if money comes in the mail then
that's not right and again that's not to
chide you boston you didn't do anything
wrong you're 22 years old you're trying
to figure this stuff out man
you're stud for even calling and putting
this stuff forward
so thank you for doing that but the the
thing is
i quit expecting you know this guy said
people change but not much you know
that's not true they do transform people
do change they can't you have the
ability and the power
you know i can do all things through
christ who strengthens me i can change
if i choose to step into it and change
right
but uh but but but if somebody's got a
pattern of doing something
and just because you like them you don't
want that pattern to be there
it's still there it's not going to just
magically go away yeah and i had to
learn that because it
bit me so many times like this guy's
broke he has no money he's disorganized
he doesn't pay his bills on time
but he promised me that's right
and that's what i do and he just he's
turned it around let's let's see what i
do
he promised me yeah it's um
it doesn't work that way you have to get
yourself almost like our last debt-free
screamer said
you know we had to get to where we got
sick and tired of not being able to
control the uncontrollables
the variables when pandemic knocks on
your door and huffs and puffs and wants
to blow your house down which it will
yep when whatever it is the the uh what
was the
you know the uh uh child uh custody
battle
right knocks on the door uh when
infertility knocks on your door
when cancer knocks on your door car
wrecks knock on your door layoffs knock
on your door
when 2008 knocks on your door when 9-1-1
knocks on your door
when black monday 1987 knocks on your
door
uh when september 23rd 1988 when i filed
bankruptcy knocks on my door
you know are you ready when the big bad
wolf huffs and he puffs are you ready be
the third pig
say never again never again this is your
never again year 2020 is not good for
much of anything
but it's a great never again year it's a
great line in the sand
right great never again here this is the
dave ramsey show dr john deloney my
co-host this hour
james childs is our producer kelly
daniel is our associate producer and
phone screener i
am dave ramsey and we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the healthcare law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
so you're going to college and you're
saying you know what i'm going to take
out student loans and when i get my job
when i get this money i can pay them
back
that's a lot keep it locked cause i'm
gonna tell you why
[Music]
let me address this up front if you
think that you're gonna take out student
loans today and it's gonna be easy
tomorrow
as in when you graduate because you're
going to have all this money
and you can pay the monthly payments you
are dreaming
a false dream the average student in
america
thinks they will make about 120
000 a year once they graduate college
and they get situated in their specific
career field but the truth of the fact
is
the average american when they graduate
college will make
in between 40 and 45 000 a year
the average student is going to graduate
with about 35 000
student loans but one out of five
students
will graduate with more than a hundred
thousand dollars in student loans
and on average you're making about forty
two thousand dollars a year
you think you're going to be comfortable
paying back that monthly payment
the average monthly payment on the low
end is 393
a month but i've met several people
who have payments anywhere between 600
to 2
000 a month that
is mind-blowing i don't want you
thinking
that if i can just get the student loans
today go through college i'm gonna have
it comfortable
four years and i'll be cool moving
forward listen to me
you're not i am meeting and mentoring
young people right now who graduated
college and they're they're not starting
families
because they have to pay back their
student loans they're not actually not
getting into their dream career field
because you know what they're paying
back student loans i'm meeting young
people who are not even buying
homes why because they can't even
qualify because
they have so much student loans student
loans
are preventing our young people from
actually enjoying their
future your student loans will prevent
you from actually growing and becoming
the young man the young woman
that you can become stop believing
this false dream you bust your butt
right now before you go to college you
look up grants you look up scholarships
maybe you don't go to your dream school
there are so many states out there right
now offering
free community college tuition or even
free
four-year university tuition programs if
you live in the state of north carolina
the north carolina has the north
carolina promise program that if you go
to a school like
unc pembroke they will actually cut your
tuition down to 500
a semester a semester
that's a four thousand dollar four-year
degree you guys
there's no reason why you have to take
out student loans but let me be real
with you
it's not gonna be easy your dream that
you really want to have
that dream is gonna require hard work
today
it's gonna require some sacrifices today
take dead off the table
bust your butt today and i promise you
tomorrow
you'll thank your younger self it's your
boy anthony o'neil keep dreaming
but don't believe in that dream peace
out
[Music]
hey guys george campbell here and i am
out of the office and downtown and
here's why
when we're at the ramsey office it's
easy to be in a bubble and be around
people who think
just like i do when it comes to money so
i thought let's get around some normal
people and see what they think
when it comes to finances we are taking
it to the street let's do it
so when did you get your first credit
card 18.
and what made you get that card
irresponsible
do you guys use credit cards right now
uh i do have one yes okay and what made
you get your first credit card
um it had it was basically free money so
the perks with it i paid off each month
so it doesn't cost me anything but
i make money on it when did you get your
first credit card
when i was probably 16
how about you i think i was 20 when i
first got mine
it was like at a macy's or whatever that
is and they're like hey you can put it
on a credit card and
you get 20 you know i was like sure and
yeah was it worth the 20
off at macy's to open the car probably
not establishing
in a lifelong of like oh i can just
charge it if i want you know
so what made you get your first credit
card um there were times where
i figured like i'm getting paid next
week but i need that money now
and also to gain the credit and get up
there to get like a head start on it
you want to work on your credit score
yeah yeah what made you get your first
credit card
um going to college just having credit
card for college
what do you need it for just i guess
spending money i didn't have okay i like
his honesty now do you guys use credit
cards
yes but only online purchases big
purchases and i pay them off straight
away so those aren't an issue with me
but
how many cards do you have i have
probably
six or seven that sounds like a lot to
keep up with yeah what made you get your
first credit card
college when i turned 17 my parents
wanted me to start
getting a credit score so when i do move
out for apartment i would
have a good credit score we try and re
wait wipe out our
our credit card bill every month how
many credit cards do you have currently
one one card okay well technically
that's a lie
i've got an australian just met each
other you're already lying to me
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand
a credit dollars that he doesn't know
about i'm gonna probably pay student
loans for the rest of my life
i just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared
welcome to the dave ramsey show you
are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense i was like i'm
gonna
do this let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
dave ramsey show where dad is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today here on the air
thank you for joining us america we're
here to talk about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight
two five five two two five
so a couple of years ago we started
putting out some small books that are
one or two chapters long we call them
quick reads
and anthony o'neil did one on paying off
student loans
we took the uh study the white paper
from the millionaire
study and turned that into a short quick
read as well with the full white paper
all the statistics and nerd stuff from
the study
uh got another one of these somewhere
who else has got one
i think those are the only two that i
know of maybe they're seem like there's
another one floating around in my mind
but anyway so john deloney comes on
board
and we immediately put together this
project it's a quick read 80 pages long
in other words a couple chapters
three chapters depending on how long you
think a chapter is but
the book is redefining anxiety it comes
out
today what anxiety is
what it's not and how to get your life
back
and uh good looking picture on there
john i tell you what i
got that photo and they said this is
gonna be the cover and i my first
thought was who's that guy
the photographers and digital editors
that we have in this building
are some of the photoshop is amazing
believe nothing you see on the internet
man
these kids are incredible and they can
make you look nice they can make you
look handsome
yeah yeah you do you look great man so
redefining anxiety what it is what it's
not and how to get your life back so if
you're suffering from anxiety or you
know someone that is
especially if someone feels like it's
kind of
a death sentence like it's chronic like
you're going to have it forever like
you're broken and this is just the way
you are
yeah right that's inaccurate that is
wrong that's right
and that's the thesis of this quick read
so be sure to pick it up there
is a light at the end of the tunnel and
no it is not
an oncoming train so there you go check
it out it's uh
daveramsey.com we're posting of course
at amazon and other places as well the
great books are sold only ten dollars
re-defining anxiety congratulations your
first ramsay publication i appreciate
that thank you much very cool
very cool good stuff open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dylan's in tucson
arizona hi dylan how are you
hey dave and dr d thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh so my my fiance and i are both 24
years old
um i'm on baby step four um and she's
currently on baby step
two she has about 28 000 in debt
um we're getting married at the end of
april uh we have enough cash to cover
the wedding
um and then i'll even have a little bit
left over
to throw on her debt after the wedding
um some of that's my
current emergency fund great plan
yeah and then after um after the wedding
after you pay off the debt
uh we plan on starting uh step 3b saving
up for a house
so my question is um in the meantime
should i continue investing my 15
um from now up until the wedding at
which point i would pause that so we can
pay down debt
or should i pause it now um and then
just pile up as much cash
as i can right now to fill up the debt
uh after the wedding
man you are on fire your critical
thinking skills are incredible those
were questions i was not asking at age
24.
god i believe man good for you dylan
i don't even know
seriously that's awesome no i would
pause and pile up cash
until you've got enough cash to cover
the wedding
her debt after the wedding uh baby step
three of an emergency fund and torn into
3b
pretty hard so yeah i'd be doing nothing
on retirement right now you need a
bigger
pile of cash as much as you can get
together dude and you are
really got this thing dialed in i'm so
proud of you very well done
is she on board with you on all this
uh she is she's not um you know i'm the
nerd she's the free spirit
um and i'm i'm obviously a way bigger
fan of you guys than she is at the
moment
um but she's on board we're actually
getting ready to take
fbu at our church um at the beginning of
next month wow
great pre-marriage counseling yeah
absolutely so we're just kind of in the
planning stages right now
um working on getting on the same page
and all that
yeah well done that's outstanding
congratulations dylan so where did you
learn how to do all this
um well you know you the dave ramsey
name has obviously
always been well known to me around the
church
you know my church always had fbu
classes and
all the you know my parents and all the
other grown-ups would always take it
um so i always knew about you once i
graduated college
uh almost two years ago um and
you know was getting ready to start my
big boy job
that's when i kind of really started
listening to you and getting into it
just because the
amount of money i was going to be making
was honestly intimidating
and you know i was kind of scared of
having all that money and not really
having a plan for it so that's cool so
basically you were you're a financial
piece baby
and so when you start having some money
you said i got to do this the grown-up
way i'm going to jive and learn how to
do it
very cool man exactly very cool i love
it well done dylan
well done that's generational stuff
right there man that's funny that's a
legacy turnover that's right that's fun
i like the second gen third gen is even
better that's cool
second ginger kids third gen's grandkids
and knowing how great grandkids are
going to be i've been nicer to their
parents
so all right steve's with us in seattle
hey steve how are you
i'm doing well how are you guys better
than i deserve what's up
hey thanks for taking my call um so
covet hit this year
wife looked at me and said get rid of
all the debt we paid off all the debt
uh we will have by january wow um
we didn't have any any personal debt it
was all
wrapped up in our business um it's
probably about 300 grand roughly
you just crushed it in a year
yeah the last few years we've been
invest reinvesting and just pouring it
right back into the business
plus we had you know obviously quite a
bit of debt um
so this year we put everything right
back into it
wow get rid of it good okay um how can i
help today
full of i got a handful of just small
little investment properties um
now i'm trying to figure out how because
i've had a plan in the years past of how
i would like to develop these
but everything involved kicking out a
loan and i'm not sure how to do it now
um cash flow i don't think you cash flow
300 grand
yeah but if i was gonna build an event
you know uh industrial park and
you're talking you know a couple of
million easy
couple hundred grand aren't you glad you
weren't doing that last year
amen this is why we don't borrow money
the number one real estate person that
goes broke are developers
because they go on the hook for millions
and the market turns and it always turns
and leaves them holding the bag
and they're screwed it's the number one
cause of real estate bankruptcy
developers
number one category so i've developed
some property but i've done it with cash
it means i have to go slower i have to
wait i have to do it by degrees or in
phases
uh you don't have to do millions of
dollars at once you can do a
300 000 street and put it in and
whatever
and get started sell off a lot and take
that lot money and then move on to the
next thing and you just do it by degrees
and by
increments uh you're right it is an
interesting intellectual challenge to
do the brain shift the way you're having
to do it the way i had to do it several
years ago
but i've never lost money as a result
since then
[Music]
hey folks chris hogan here do you feel
like you've tried everything to get your
finances in order
but you still can't get any traction
maybe you've tried budgeting
but life happened and you couldn't stick
with it or you've set goals to save and
invest
but can't get a hit because debt is
eating away at your paycheck
i've been there it's painful i'm gonna
be real with you okay
you already have the ability to build
wealth and find financial peace
inside of you you just need the right
coach
to help you get there people who work
with a coach
get results in fact they get fantastic
results
heck i even have a coach every success
story
involves a coach someone cheering you on
and offering guidance if you want to
continue to get the same results in your
financial life
keep doing the same thing but if you're
ready to win
get a financial coach it's the most
effective way to accomplish your
financial goals
and dreams how do i know i've spent over
a decade
working as a financial coach for dave
ramsey's team
and here's what i found financial
coaching is all about helping you
make your financial dreams a reality
coaches aren't out to sell you anything
like
investments or insurance they help you
understand what's holding you back in
your finances
build a plan to help you get to where
you want to be and walk with you
on your journey now here's the good news
we have a network of trained financial
coaches all across the country
who are ready to work with you they're
called ramsey
preferred coaches and they're the best
at what they do
they seek to understand your specific
challenges and help you
build a tailored plan to accomplish your
financial goals
you hear that that voice in your head
that makes you feel
scared or vulnerable that's the same
voice keeping you
from reaching your dreams so tell it to
shut up don't make excuses
make progress
one one thousand dollars to start your
emergency fund
step two pay off all debt using the debt
snowball
step three three to six months of
expenses
in savings step four invest fifteen
percent of household income
in roth iras and pre-tax retirement
step five college funding for children
step six pay off house early
step seven build wealth and give
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and i've been saying this for years
don't do it
what's going on out there that's contin
allowing this industry to just continue
dave it's greed and honestly this isn't
going to change
until the industry decides to recognize
that they have a customer service
nightmare because of a terrible product
they're not taking care of their of
their customers which is why we're
flooded with calls every day time sure
exit team is different i mean we
we now have you know almost 20 000
people out of timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
yes
if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you'll get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal john our question today's
question comes from
chad in utah my wife has been diagnosed
with disassociative identity disorder
otherwise known as multiple
personalities
too often when she goes shopping some of
her younger identities come up and she
ends up spending money that we just
don't have
then she gets home and feels bad about
her purchases but is too ashamed to take
things back
we are in baby step 2 and working toward
getting our debts paid off but it's
going extraordinarily slow because of
this
my question is what advice would you
have to help curb the
curb the spending aside from simply
taking over the money i just don't know
what else to do
you got to simply take over the money
yep um you got to take
the debit card out of her hands you'll
have to when she is
in what i would call when she's got her
central state when her central identity
is running the show you got to make sure
that um she turns over all of her
spending and your job is now to
go to the store you're working with
someone who's not fully well and until
she can
integrate some of that and that's a hard
long process
um you're going to be running the show
when it comes to the money yeah
if she is not um
if we were to if if say someone has
dementia
as an example they are of diminished
capacity
right from a legal standpoint and so you
could take
your your grandpa into the judge
with the doc's letters and say grandpa's
of diminished capacity we need to take
over and take
you know they appoint a guardian and
light them and you don't ask
someone who is of diminished capacity to
make
quality decisions for themselves right
and
uh and and so from a legal standpoint
you don't have to do that legally in
this case but uh you literally take over
someone's finances for their own good
that's right not for your good
but um because they're not capable of
doing it in
their current state uh hopefully
there's some work that can be done and
this is not a permanent
thing but uh but basically you're um
she's got a mental illness and you're
caring for
a wife who has a mental illness that's
right and i would recommend chad i
recommend you get a friend or an
accountability partner that will walk
with you because she may not be able to
carry that load right now
and that's the season y'all are in and
you may be in this road for a long
time right um this is a very very rare
disorder
um despite how much attention it gets on
tv and whatnot
and you may be in it for a while so get
somebody you can walk along with you
that will cheer you on that will be
frustrated with you
and we'll help you make good decisions
but yeah this is your this is your
your road to home my man i'll give you
another one okay something as simple as
i've worked with over the years uh
uh someone who's recovering uh from a
gambling addiction
you can they can't touch money right
until they've got six months clean
and then they can only touch certain
amounts and then they gotta have another
six months clean and then they can only
touch
certain amounts and then you know when
you got two years clean we could talk
about i've been joined accounts again
right but otherwise i'm just going to
take care of you right because when you
touch money you
can't do it that's right and so it's not
good for you it's not good for us
and um so you're expecting something of
her that she does not have the
strength and capacity to deliver which
is called self-discipline that's right
and so you've got to step in and do that
very interesting let me ask you this
when i read this
um because i know nothing about this i
mean other than
i know what this is but uh you know from
the three psych classes i had in my life
but you know but uh uh how often is
something like this
misdiagnosed significantly
massively massively true dissociative
identity disorder is super super rare
and it's just it's a splintering of your
identities it's less about you've got
different people living inside of you
and more
you've got identities usually it stems
from really
significant trauma from childhood and
you've got different
identities that will rise up and take
care of different things like scary
moments and joyful moments
and there may be something around money
or stores or responsibility that this
jack's wife reverts back and usually
there's one that's a quarterback
there's some interesting stuff man you
can look at the brain images change
uh blood pressure changes um and true
diagnostics it's
it's really bizarre but it's very it's
incredible but it's very very rare right
yeah so
um maybe not in this situation but maybe
if someone thought they had that it
could be that it's almost like
we're trying to give something a label
where i'm just refusing to control
myself
occasionally usually if you've got it's
just the younger me i need a victim
yeah if if i would go see somebody twice
i'd go see two different people who
diagnosed me with this
um i would not absolutely 100 you can't
self-diagnose this
no right and sometimes dealing with
trauma
uh and i can't un-diagnose it sitting
here obviously either and that's not
what i'm trying to do in their situation
i just uh you know part of part there's
a little part of me that wonders you
know
the younger identity i i just i've heard
so many people have so many excuses
over the years on why they will not
control their spending that's exactly
right
and i'm not saying that's the case with
her but i just i'm always leery
that's right and again in these rare
rare moments
yeah the the working together working
together means you're taking over
right yeah yeah you're just because
you're just our diminished capacity
that's right that's
different than i refuse to or it makes
me scared to win or it reminds me when i
was a kid and
that's not those are different that's a
lot of different different that's a
difference in a ten and a two
yeah this you're talking your heart rate
changes your blood pressure
i've seen some where vocal cords reshift
some are smoking and some don't smoke i
mean it's
you're talking dramatic and it's super
rare and
like i said if if someone i love was
diagnosed with this i would be on the
phone with another doctor immediately to
get
um a completely new work up to see if
this was
with this is accurate and true very
interesting yeah yeah it probably shows
up in the movies more than in real life
way more in the movies that's right
okay yeah open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and by the way just in
case some of you misheard that
and neither one of us are saying that is
the case with chad's wife
absolutely it's just a discussion
because this kind of thing comes up
uh behaviors and mental illnesses and
diagnosis you know bipolar is the one i
do get a lot we get that a lot and
and that's much more frequent yeah and
we're dave we're living in a world where
you can only get reimbursed from
insurance with a diagnosis
and so there is a there is a tendency
there is an incentive to
give a diagnosis which means get labeled
get labeled
we live in a world where we overnight
literally 10 years ago we all got access
to everybody's information
without the training that goes with
deciphering some of that information and
so we all have become armchair
quarterbacks when it comes to what you
have what i have
pop psychologists and then the third is
we are all looking for a reason why
like we talked about in the last segment
why we can't just grind out and do the
hard
small steps that is every day and you
take all three of those together and
yeah you get
diagnosis all over the place you get
people diagnosing themselves
prescriptions issues like their tic tacs
and
then look around we got a mess right
yeah but that doesn't undermine
there are very real psychological
challenges that people experience
absolutely they do there's no question
just we're living in attention we're not
trying to be cold in that right now i
didn't hear that at all yeah
no i'm and i'm just saying neither one
of us are saying that about his wife
yeah
because we don't know in that situation
but if that is truly what's going on
and it sounds like it is then yes you
you cannot
she cannot handle money until she has a
level of healing
past that um and if you're you know if
you have someone that's dealing with
gambling addiction they cannot touch
money
if they're dealing with a pornography
addiction they cannot touch money matter
of fact if they're dealing with an
addiction
they just can't touch money because
addicts 100 of addicts are broke
eventually
it's the gasoline for their fire right
eventually they're going to spend money
on their thing whatever it is they're
addicted to to the point they destroy
their family and themselves
eventually there are no such thing as
rich addicts
hmm that remain rich foreign rich that's
right eventually they're gonna snort
their thing
their fortune away or uh you know
it goes from porn to prostitutes or
whatever and
um you know gambling is pretty quick you
can run through the money with gambling
open up your computer and you can go
through about a hundred thousand dollars
in 20 minutes
um there's always someone on the street
corner to give you some more right oh
yeah
absolutely there's a though there's a
you know the internet will hook you up
baby
and um we're now seeing the fastest
growing addiction
in our offices for financial counseling
is porn really
second is gambling because of internet
access that's right driven it through
the roof
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we met on a blind date that i kept
canceling because
i wasn't kept telling my friend i'm not
interested
and finally she said you're going to
meet him
and so i went we hit it off and just
we were married within a few months
in january of 2012 he had a heart attack
here at home and we lost him the next
day
[Music]
my name is ruth and i live in engleton
texas
and i'm a teacher it is difficult being
a single mom
i did lots of things to make extra
income i taught summer school every
summer
i tutored so that eventually my daughter
and i were able to move out on our own
and then finally i met my husband and
it was a second marriage for both of us
and we hadn't been together very long
when he found out
i'd never been out of texas and so we
began to travel
quite a bit we took a lot of wonderful
trips
and if we didn't have the cash we used
the credit cards
i'm glad i have those memories but after
he died
i wasn't so it wasn't so easy to pay for
them alone
the phone rang and it was the credit
card company
they were telling me you know that they
wanted to talk about my outstanding
ballots and
you know i got the bill out and i was
looking at it and i said well you know
i'm sending you 500
a month and the debt is growing because
you defaulted the interest rate
i said i'm not i'm not i don't know how
you expect me to ever pay you off or how
to even break even
he said something about it being an
amount this this large
it would be something that we would
litigate it's not something that we're
just going to write off and
and i just burst into tears
i said well then i guess i'll take your
500 payment
and i'll hire a bankruptcy attorney i
was transferred to a
supervisor who did work out a payment
plan for me
when i got off the phone i just started
crying all over again because i was
humiliated
and i remember i walked for a long time
just thinking about my life in financial
terms i can remember the exact spot
where i was standing when i had that
thought that this is it
i am going to pay this off and i am
never
ever going to take on a debt again i
don't ever
again want to feel this way
and that was my turning point that is
when
i just said i'm done with dead i don't
care
and i'd stumbled upon the dave ramsey
plan
the message that he taught was simple
and basic
it really wasn't anything i hadn't heard
or read before but it was just the way
he presented it
what i found within a week
was those cash envelopes that was real
freedom
44 months after the day that the
creditor called me and left me in tears
i paid it off
and so after all that it was um right at
38
a little over 38 000 and every day since
it's just been
a peaceful quiet day
and then i just got back a week ago from
my first
real vacation that i've taken since he
passed away i feel empowered i
want to go on a trip next summer with
the same group of friends we're already
planning our trip and i know how
to make it happen it was very difficult
at times it was very emotional at times
i i don't have a single regret
[Music]
i am happy and i'm inspired that what
does the future
hold for me three two
one i am debt free
first decided to sell our home the first
decision we wanted to make was to find a
real estate agent
there are so many options out there
knowing
that you're going to pick someone
ethical someone that's going to
help you get the most out of your house
we went online to the dave ramsey
website and
sign up to ask for help from an elp and
we put in our information and it was
like
instant i wanted someone that could
guide us into the right kind of house in
the right place
and that's what we found with troy
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage j.r and kylie
are with us hey guys how are you great
you're doing great dave
welcome welcome so you're here to do a
debt free stream yes
how much have you paid off six 266
dollars seven hundred eleven dollars and
ten cents my goodness how long did this
take
four years two months in 17 days
plus or minus a little stork mode in
there so we have a nine month old
daughter
love it she's back in nebraska so
wonderful
very cool and your range of income
during the four years
we started out at about 78 000 and now
we're up to
115. very good what do you guys do for a
living
i'm in logistics and transportation and
i do
trade association management so we just
went through the ems
um entre leadership oh good yeah very
good
were you here in person or on the stream
here yeah okay great very good well
thank you for coming yeah
very fun so uh 267 000 over four years
did you pay off your house we well you
don't
well we uh about twenty four thousand
was uh cars thirty thousand was student
or no thirty thousand was credit cards
and then about eighty thousand was
um student loans and then yeah we had a
hundred and thirty two thousand dollar
mortgage and we had talked
um kind of about moving back home and uh
opportunity came up
we have from a really small town so we
sold our house and we bought our current
house with cash all right
very cool long answer yeah we did yeah
but there's a little gyration to get
there yeah okay very cool
i love it paying cash was definitely
like people like what are you doing
this is what we need to do we're for
sure we're sure this is the right move
so
yeah wow so what's the house worth that
you just bought um we bought it for 80
and it's down to the studs right now so
it needs a little love
depth desperate need of drywall but once
we're done a couple of just sold around
the area so about 130 to 150.
excellent how old are you two i'm 31
about to be 32.
28. and you have a paid for house yes we
do
you're so weird man way to go you guys
so what did the what did the the folks
in the mortgage process
tell you as you were you know met with
your realtors they were gonna buy this
with cash then you went to closing with
cash you wrote a check
did people look at you weird a little
bit yeah people i think people are like
make sure you borrow a little bit more
so you can cover your renovations and
we were like no we gotta do the baby
steps we have to make sure we have
enough for baby step three we gotta make
sure we can pay cash we have to make
sure we can afford to renovate it
and so we kind of just really made sure
we had a plan so that we weren't jumping
ahead or getting ahead so we did baby
steps
you had a plan so i told you you were
weird
she's definitely the planner of us too
so i love it
you both seem like a very precise couple
the numbers you gave were down to the
to the to the hundredths right yeah what
do you all do for fun
uh well when we're not paying off debt
uh we're tearing out
tearing up plaster and laugh and travel
um
husker football yeah yeah back and forth
to nashville a lot lately yeah yeah yeah
we just come to nashville for fun yeah
come see you guys
well way to go guys so i mean you've
been on quite a journey
we haven't have you even breathed it in
that you're a hundred percent debt-free
yeah
it's taken a little while to kind of get
used to but um
you know as like the paychecks start
coming in and we don't have the mortgage
or the loan payments to pay it's like
what almost like we have so much margin
in our budgets what do we do with
all that money really so uh the
budgeting process is a little bit
different to kind of get used to that
but it's
yeah it's been awesome yeah way to go
you guys i think the biggest thing for
us like just going into
work and like we both enjoy our jobs but
just going into work and knowing we're
choosing to be there we're not feeling
the pinch of
i gotta get this paycheck i gotta i have
to make the ends meet
like we choose to go to our jobs every
day and we're not
right we just know that we're there and
we want to be there and i think it makes
us better employees too
yeah and absolutely we we coordinate the
class and um we're doing one right now
and we had lesson two last night about
dumping debt
and dave you have that part about like
you're walking out like where are you
going i don't have any payments
so we can definitely relate to that has
it hit you yet
that your nine month old daughter will
have none of these experiences
won't have that stress those late night
pacing around your house
she won't deal with that she's going to
have a totally new family tree because
of the work you did
yeah that's something that i kind of
thought about a lot throughout the
process too when we first got pregnant
and then
when she was here because like as a kid
you know
our family wasn't very financially set
so um
my childhood was not as as good as i
wanted to be so hers is going to be
definitely
way better that's incredible i think
just seeing her and having her around
just like
gave us that push to kind of like really
go after it to know like
we and we don't want to have to
constantly feel this pinch all the time
or say no
all the time so yeah live like no one
else so later and i can live and give
like no one else
right i love it way to go you guys
who are you're so you're leading a
financial peace class yep our fourth one
okay wow so what started the whole
journey four years ago did i ask you
that already
well it started about five years ago um
i
was going on a trip up to canada a
fishing trip up to canada with some
buddies and we drove
about 14 hours from lincoln up to canada
and the driver who controls the radio
was also a big fan of here so we got
about 14 hours of dave ramsey
so we've we've coined it as the ramsey
road trip now oh
i don't want to go on that trail i've
listened to 14 straight hours of my boss
and it's a lot so congratulations they
jumped out of that truck though like we
can sell the boat we can sell our guns
we can sell our truck we can sell
what can we sell what what i was like
what is this where did you guys go i
thought you were on a fishing trip
yeah she kind of thought it was a racket
at first and she's like i got my own gal
that i get my financial advice from
and then about a year later is when we
got married and kind of decided
yeah that's when we need to get on track
so one of your first orders of business
and marriage just dive into this plan
yep after the honeymoon phase we got
back and
yeah took a couple weeks we started the
spreadsheet yeah oh
that was fresh the planner begins the
plan
the budget meetings i like it the tears
so uh who were your biggest cheerleaders
i think leading the class
really gave us a lot of accountability i
was we took the class
we had just a shout out to nick wagner
he um
was our coordinator and he's just done
so much for our family in the last
um yeah it's just been so helpful and
so that was really helpful for us
accountability wise to just like have
that nine weeks of just really getting
after it but then
coordinating the class like you have to
you have to do what you're
what you're coordinating what the class
says and you have to live that out and
people are listening so
teaching the class really helped us and
we had so many class members that really
rallied behind us and
just just really told us like you guys
are doing great this is awesome we can't
wait to get to where you're at
and that gave us a lot of accountability
in our church in kansas city where we
lived before it was
amazing our church family was huge and
like which church were you in casey
christ community the downtown campus
yeah okay very cool
very cool good for you guys well done
well done well we've got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires you know the drill it's
always the
that's the next chapter in your story uh
and you've proven that you know how to
do this
you have paid for house you're 28 years
old just shut up i mean my gosh this is
amazing i'm so proud of y'all you're
heroes thank you
so very well done so very well done yeah
your next chapter is to be everyday
millionaires that's the next chapter in
your story it doesn't end here
you got out of debt so that exactly
right so that is what's important
yeah one of the classes that we had led
was during the margin kc
um kansas city classes so that was very
cool to kind of be a part
of like the citywide movement yeah and
we talked about that a lot too like the
feeling of peace for me is just having
so much margin and so
yeah that's what that that campaign was
called margin yep yeah uh randy frazier
the pastor
uh up there got that started as a friend
of mine yeah well done you guys
very very very well done all right here
it is
jr and kylie lincoln nebraska 267
thousand dollars paid off four years in
two months seventy eight thousand to 115
income
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're done
wow oh that's so cool man
man the math on this 32 years old making
115
yeah you know where they're going to be
at 42 where they're gonna be at 52 where
they're gonna be at 62.
it's tens of millions of dollars right i
mean they're gonna be
wow what a deal what an impressive young
couple it's incredible guys and uh
if you're listening out there maybe
that's the first time you've ever heard
this
it's your turn you can you can do this
you can do this i'm talking to you right
there
yeah you this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
we started five daughters bakery solely
on
the idea of being together my husband
and i
really love to work together we enjoy
being around each other
and we loved being with our family so we
have five daughters who are growing and
time is fleeting
and we wanted to spend more time as a
family we were in a season of life where
we knew we were on the brink of
breakthrough and change
and we just knew that we needed to do
something different and very
counter-cultural
than the nine-to-five job when we got
started we
absolutely felt fearful definitely
unqualified
neither my husband or i have any
experience
in the restaurant industry we were just
baking in our kitchen
praying over little donuts in a tiny
fryer and when we first came in
honest coffee roasters they took us on
and we built momentum with them selling
out every day and people really started
to get word of our business in the
community
and so we got really excited we started
to go ask other people
do you want our donuts and we got a lot
of closed doors in our face
and so it was like well god we thought
we were stepping out we thought we had
this momentum we thought we were moving
you know those setbacks kind of made us
question in doubt did we do the right
thing is this what we're supposed to do
with those challenges we learned
that for our story and for our journey
we were to stop
and wait for open doors we weren't to
push things open
but we were to rest and hear his voice
and look for green lights
and move upon that step by step when
things get hard my motivation to keep
going
is to look at the faces of the people
who've poured their hearts and souls out
into our bakery and have taken ownership
over that the motivation
to not give up is when i look at my
children and i
i need to show them what it looks like
to become an overcomer to persevere
to keep going it's just been a blessing
for our family to actually integrate
and work together we get to build a team
together we get to envision what it's
going to look like moving forward and we
get to
be wild because it's our life and we get
to write that story together with god
when our kids see us walking out our
dreams it's really empowering to me as a
mom
for them to see us being leaders in the
community for them to see us wearing
different hats
solving conflicts relating with other
people
that's important to us because it's
building trust and sowing truth into
their hearts about
us chasing our dreams just want to speak
to the moms out there
running a business is a lot of work but
it's very rewarding
and what you actually care about and
dream about and desire
is important so don't give up you're
important to this world
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national
guard not only are they big supporters
of our high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
folks if you're like most people in
america your car has gotten a little
dustier this
year some car companies have already
started giving credits for about 15
percent of your premium
now obviously if you're confident you're
paying the lowest possible price go
ahead and take the credit
but if you're not confident don't settle
for a skimpy seventy dollars you might
be missing out on as much as seven
hundred dollar savings
which is most people who work with an
endorsed local provider for car
insurance with us
people we endorse for that they shop
around among several different companies
get you the best deal
the average savings is seven hundred
dollars wow
so have somebody shop for you text auto
to 33
789 that's auto two three three
seven eight nine another important thing
that i forgot to mention earlier is that
we are giving away
five hundred dollars a week between now
and christmas with a five thousand
dollar grand prize giveaway in the
ramsey
christmas giveaway if you're looking for
life-changing gifts
uh check it out the famous ten dollar
sale is at the store
you do not have to do a purchase of any
kind to register for the 500
giveaway but the ten dollar total money
makeover books are there
john deloney's brand new quick read
redefining anxiety
it's only 10 bucks and uh all the other
best sellers that we've had are all
there for
10 so enter to win
get some cash and even save some money
by getting some deals on these books and
other things
that we have daveramsey.com
giveaway jake's with us in salt lake
city hey jake welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave and dr john how's it going great
how can we help
so i've been working in the live event
industry building producing concerts
trade shows and other live events
when i was 18. oh my god and i'm 18
or sorry i'm 28 now and i've been
training through years of on-the-job
training
but i'm getting married next month
and i have no income right now and so
i'm trying to see what advice you guys
have
for restarting with a new career
well you need to um uh because i
i mean i i think live events will be
back someday but i don't know when
um i don't know anything apparently
based on my predictions for this cat
last year but
um i mean we are doing some events but
we're one of the few companies in the
world that are
and they're very small and uh we're
doing a lot of streaming
stuff um of course but that's more like
video production than it is doing live
events
so you're you're right um if
um yeah if you were marrying my daughter
i would say get a new career
right yeah for now anyway what are you
jake are you just grinding something out
right now are you delivering are you
just putting it together are you making
a living right now
so i've been working for an amusement
park that i worked for right out of high
school
but our season ended the first week of
november so now i'm
to a point where even that income's gone
so now i need to
see what i'm doing what do you want to
do man
that's a hard question because you know
i've been for
10 years i've been doing that so trying
to find something else
where in what i've worked
so hard to build that's really difficult
so i i'm gonna i'm gonna let dave handle
the or answer the
the career part of it i want you to make
sure you don't miss the opportunity to
mourn this
and put a period at the end of it if
you're actually going to change careers
otherwise it's going to hang on you and
it's going to drag on you
and there's something about having a
process about just stopping getting a
couple of people together
and talking about how great it was
and um putting an end to it otherwise
it's just gonna haunt you yeah ride it
up and burn it in the fire pit in the
backyard
make sure you mourn it it sucks man i
wish there was a nicer way to
to say it and to cheer you on and say
hey it'll be back we don't know man we
just don't know
and make sure you mourn it before you
transition and then you can look at this
as an opportunity to go do something
that you had burning way and deep inside
of you or something different
or you may have to grind it up for a
while okay so
if you're like our live event team uh
you've developed some skills that are
transferable
uh one thing is is that uh you know how
to
uh change and make new decisions very
quickly to a new end
because you run into um the unknown
frequently uh you roll up on a place and
you're supposed to
have a an event go a certain way and all
of a sudden there's 73
obstacles that were not in the contract
uh that are thrown in the way
uh whether it's difficult people or
a difficult venue and the load-in dock
isn't what it was supposed to be the
lighting tree wasn't where it was
supposed to be whatever it is
and there's a lot of fast decisions and
quick decisions and moving and pivoting
and being flexible
uh so you're not going to be a very good
bureaucrat you're the opposite end of
the spectrum does that make sense
absolutely yeah you don't you do not
want to get tied into something that is
extremely processed and rigid driven
if it's rigid it's going to kill you
because you are anything but rigid if
you're like our guys
because we have to make up crap on the
fly sometimes up to three minutes before
i walk on the stage
so you also are very gifted at speaking
diva
you're going to be great at working with
ceos with executives with leaders
and able to get people to get the best
out of themselves
and also be able to just smile and say
you got it and go
go get a job done right when that buries
some people and you've been there
that's right you've been there you know
how to just take it and move on and
get to get a get a good show done and
that's a gift man
yeah that's yeah i think there's working
with uh
personalities and unusual situations and
high stress scenarios and still getting
something done
is a transferable skill we just have to
think about
where that is and who that's too most of
our businesses have all been run
that way this year i think we had an
advantage at ramsey solutions because we
have a huge live event department that
um
and i've been neck deep in it for 30
years so
i i you know when we had to pivot and
change a whole bunch of stuff around
here quickly
then we kind of had that skill set even
and just transferred it into some of the
other business units
and um so things where things have to
change and we're difficult people and
obstacles are there
that's a good place where you're going
to thrive because it's it gives you
energy that's the thing
and the um
trying to think what that is but i don't
know so i mean i ran into somebody i'm
playing my
i'm trying to channel my inner ken
coleman here yeah i ran into somebody
here in the hallway today and i said
what gang are you with which team here
at ramsey are you with and he said well
i was with live events and now i'm
helping out with the
concierge team able to answer some
questions give people the
help they need able to take somebody who
thinks they're in a
in a solution free environment and give
them some other options and that's all
stuff they've done backstage yeah talk
them off the cliff that's right and so
whether it's customer service whether
it's possible
hostage negotiator that's right man
there's
it's it's really endless um and i think
he's gonna have to
to find jake's gonna have to find that
balance between grinding some mountain
you gotta get some money coming in
whatever that looks like i think you go
all the way back to whiteboard and like
you were 18 years old or something and
go okay
uh what do i do with my life now that i
know that i know this about me
right because you know what your skills
are you know what your talents are
and um ken coleman talks about the sweet
spot where your talents intersect your
uh your passions and uh you you've got
certain
passions and certain talents that have
been revealed in this ten years of
experience so it's not
wasted that's right it's not a it's not
a clever waste it's not a cold stop and
restart
right as much as it feels like it is so
i'm going to give you a copy of ken's
book
uh the proximity principle and i want
you to go to kencoleman.com start
listening to his podcast you may even
call in and talk to him he probably more
helpful
to you than we were but uh also you can
download
tons of uh free uh pdf things that will
guide you through the process
of self-discovery uh and getting clear
on where you wanna go and then once you
get clear then you just got to execute
and go land there
but i think it starts with mourning the
end of something
so many people get fired they get laid
off they get furloughed
and they just go run jump into the next
thing and that's very similar to
somebody divorcing you and the day after
divorce you just run in and
and marry somebody like you gotta stop
pause
mourn that sucker and then extract the
lessons that it taught you before you
just run off into the woods right yeah
yeah i mean it is sad to have
loss it is no matter what the loss is
and we all have them there's sadness
and we've had a bunch of this year big
ones small ones yeah
you know and just to say that out loud
is okay it doesn't make you
you know a bad person it doesn't make
you a child it doesn't make you
you know any of those kind of things
you're wise yeah yeah you just go that
hurt
ouch right you know and then go take the
next wobbly step
right exactly exactly hang on kelly i'll
pick up we'll get you a copy of ken's
book and hopefully that'll help you jack
we empathize with you brother cause we
got a bunch of people around here in the
same situation
we're working them this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way just like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit go today
and take advantage of this week's
special offer
[Music]
if you're single okay if you're single
and you want to be a good steward of
this season
that we are in yes you and i
i want you to figure out who you are and
where you're going
let me say it again number one i want
you to figure out who you are
[Music]
who did god create you to be and
where are you going in life
i want you to set a clear vision for
your career
for your your life for your goals
for where are you going i don't want you
to be
a single person and you're waiting on
another individual to make you
most uh most times when i when i i'm
talking to single ladies
they're like well you know i don't
really want to you know just get all
these
plans because i i just i want to make
sure that i save room for my husband
oh well wait i love the fact that you
want to save room for your husband to
come in and y'all build something
together
but god made you he gave you
an assignment you go after that
assignment
you see because um i believe that when
we are operated within god's
perfect will not his permissive field
his perfect
will that's when i believe
two that come together will be blessed
if if god called me to do what i'm doing
today
and if god called my wife to do what
she's doing today
god is going to honor that and he's
going to bless that because we're doing
exactly
what we were created to do
singleness is the perfect time to find
you you don't need someone else to
define
you use this time in your singleness
in our singleness to define
you you know some of my goals during
this season
that i'm in is to make sure
that my mental health is well
you know a few years ago i was engaged
to an amazing young lady you all hear me
say this all the time
and i just knew i was about to be
married i just knew how i was about to
become a father then all of a sudden
i had to walk away from it because it
was the best thing for the both of us
and during that time one of the very
first things that my mentor said is all
right
you need to define you better you need
to focus on you
you need to get clear with where you're
going and how you're going there
i just started with ramsey solutions and
just joined the speakers team here and
i said all right i want to become one of
the best speakers that that
impacts young people and millennials
help them become debt free
help them start a successful life help
them get over some of the roadblocks
that
some of them are facing so i really just
got focused with my team and said hey
i want a youtube channel hey i want to
travel the world hey i want to really
use this time
wisely to make sure that i'm defining
and finding me but while i'm doing that
i'm helping
you use this time
to figure out who you are and where
you're going and while you're figuring
out who you are and where you're going
make sure you're helping someone else
make sure you're serving someone
else make sure that you're putting a
smile on some
one else at the end of the day
i want you to take some time to pray and
seriously reflect on
who you are and where you are
going
[Music]
i made as many mistakes as far as taxes
were concerned
[Music]
and we wanted to do things correctly we
got very frustrated knowing that there's
got to be a better way to do this
[Music]
around here we're big believers and high
quality real estate agents
that's why we found the best agents in
your area to work directly
with you these folks actually care about
your financial journey
they hate debt as much as you do and
won't sweet talk you into accepting a
deal you're not comfortable with
oh yeah and there's no extra fee to work
with them you'll get access to the
profiles of trusted agents in your area
you can expect those agents to contact
you directly in less than 24 hours
it doesn't matter if you're buying or
selling or both
we're here to help so if you're ready to
get started
let us help make this experience simple
and rewarding
with the top trusted endorsed local
providers in your area
go to daveramsey.com agents and find
your agent today
[Music]
hello everyone i've got a question for
you do you know your net worth
you see there's a lot of confusion out
there about net worth
i mean people think only celebrities
have a net worth that's not the case
everyone has one but what we have to do
is understand how to do this
well here's what you do net worth is
defined by taking what you own
minus what you owe and that gives you
your net worth
you see understanding this is crucial to
you beginning your journey to becoming
an everyday millionaire
we've got to know the start point but we
also have to have a game plan
that's why we developed the network
calculator it's six easy questions
tailored to help you to understand where
you are and to know your net worth
you can do this and i'm here to help all
you have to do is enter your email
address to get started
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i want him to come clean about a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense i was like i'm
gonna
do this let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host
we appreciate you calling and being part
of the program dr john deloney
is our co-host today ramsey personality
author of the new
ramsay quick read redefining anxiety
you need to pick up a copy of this it's
80 pages long our quick reads are a
couple chapters worth
what it is what it's not and how to get
your life back redefining
anxiety if you have had issues with
anxiety
um this year or recently or you know
someone that you love that has
uh this may give you a whole new
perspective a book comes out or the
quick read comes out today uh and uh
be sure and check it out it's only ten
dollars as i said these quick reads are
usually anywhere from 50 to 80 pages
that kind of a thing i think we did one
that was 37 pages so
uh it's the idea of you you get some
really good information in a very
concise
um quick read i would say if you know
people in your life
this year that haven't been anxious you
should probably call someone and have
them checked out
well everybody's had it these are well i
think the
difference in what this is this is not
if you have ever felt anxious this year
though this book is not for you
nope this is about if you've been
diagnosed by yourself or anyone else as
having anxiety or you you have an
anxiety disorder
right along those lines that's what
you're addressing with this right yeah
and it's bigger than that it's the the
ecosystem that we live is just
unsustainable it's a mess and people
aren't being intentional with their
living
they are um being told that they're
broken
that they are machines and they're their
operating software doesn't work anymore
and sorry about that we got some
solutions for you
they're going to cost you some money and
force you down some avenues that you may
have not considered and
yeah it's just a great way to reimagine
life
and get your life back tony is going to
start off this
hour in new york city hi tony welcome to
the dave ramsey show
what's up dave what's up john how are
you guys great man how can we help
yeah so i'm a 22 year old college senior
i got one year left
um i have no debt my mom paid cash for
the school so i'm good
wow um i had a job back in march
um but i lost it because it covered and
uh so i just decided to sign up for
unemployment because
all of my friends were kind of doing it
and i ended up getting about 18 000 from
unemployment
i'm guessing that's free money i don't
know if it's taxable actually they took
out taxes
um and so um i was wondering like what's
like the best way for me to go
so that i can basically like be
financially free or like wealthy like
how you call it because i just found you
like a day yesterday actually
oh my goodness well well done sir so
what is your degree in
going to be in so i'm setting up finance
okay and the the the job that you had
lined up was
for for after you completed your degree
no it was just a job just for income for
money oh i see
okay and you graduate when now i
graduated two semesters
so this time next year yeah about
okay all right well i think you hold on
to that money to ensure that you
graduate
and continue the debt-free journey that
you're on which is absolutely awesome
that's very very cool have you hugged
your mom today tony
you told her that you loved her and she
set you up to win
i probably should but did you say that
tony every day you wake up you go tell
that lady
thank you for setting me up for for a
life
yeah that is going to be debt-free it's
it's yeah because it's just wonderful
very few people get the gift that you've
gotten here so
it's just i'm very lucky for you i just
wanted to know like what's like the best
way for me like it's
it's not the best question but it's very
general but like
what's the best way for me to to get
wealthy like
like i don't want to say rich but like
wealthy is like the best way
yeah well either one's okay
neither one are immoral it's not immoral
to be rich it's not immoral
you're not a bad person automatically if
you're wealthy and
so one thing you do want to do is break
that out of your head uh
and and so because if you're other
centered
you can do a lot of wonderful things
with money like your mom did
okay she used money to do this wonderful
thing for you and you'll be able to do
that
uh yourself many times over so yeah
it's a big question it's probably too
big for a radio answer
i'll tell you the biggest thing a couple
things number one is
to be doing what you're doing now gather
knowledge be very
intentional with your money most people
just kind of wander along and then
wonder what happened
and if you'll just be very intentional
then that will lead you to
doing a budget that will lead you to
living on less than you make
that will lead you to generosity that
will lead you to
avoiding debt uh that will lead you to
investing and those are the keys
to building wealth but no one does that
accidentally no one wins the super bowl
on
accident it's an intentional act
and so just by asking the question
you've started that process
of being intentional so dave there's a
lot of media sensations
that that pop up with you know a couple
of college friends come up with an idea
and they
they have an ipo and they turn into
overnight this is and that's
is it been your experience though that
the the vast majority of people who
build and i love
that he already knows the distinction
here to build wealth
it takes a long time doesn't it yeah get
rich quick just does not work
right statistically uh it's so it's so
rare
and the interesting thing is those that
do it very seldom keep it
and so because they didn't build the
infrastructure in their character to
carry it
and it well i like that it fritters away
you build the muscles by increment
by struggle after struggle after
struggle because a muscle is a
built by tearing muscle is built by
destruction
by by pain it is not built by comfort
and so that that gradual over a 10
12 15 year period of uh
uh of staying out of debt living on a
lesson you make being intentional
uh doing some things that your friends
don't do uh
not doing a bunch of things your friends
do do you know and that kind of a thing
you have a life but you're just very
smart and wise about it over a period of
time that is how wealth is built
i talked to a young man this morning 35
years old came up to me and whispered
and said i'm an everyday millionaire
wow and uh works on our team really
yeah wow walked up to me after staff
meeting and said i'm an everyday
millionaire 35 i said how old are you
35. i mean he said i started working
your plan 12 years ago
just out of college he said i've all
we've always lived
exactly what we teach here to the dime
to the penny
you know intentional and uh he makes
good money but he does you know
yeah he he didn't get paid a million
dollars a year i'll tell you that
millionaire money right no he didn't
make millionaire money but he is
right because he just just that steady
the tortoise wins the race not the hair
every time yeah and that's the you know
all the data we have on millionaires
tells us that's how they do it
and that same idea works for marriages
for mental health for physical health
for weight loss
yeah you said that right when i came on
i don't even know if you remember saying
that to me but you said john i've read
that book the tortoise in the hair a
whole bunch
and the tortoise wins every single time
beverly hills said there's no
shortcut to any place worth going i love
it it's just that's the process
sorry me good for you brother hang on
tony we're gonna give you a copy of the
book the total money makeover
which has shown eight million people how
to answer the question you're asking
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
boys
[Music]
all right let me take you back to
january 2018.
i was making my new year's resolutions
like everyone in america does and i said
you know what
i'm going to start working out again
i'm going to start you know really
i was actually honestly just feeling so
like oh caroline was like six months old
i was so tired
every time in the monitor she would cry
in the mornings i was like dragging
myself out of bed i was like i just i
need
i need to be energized and i remember
when i used to work out i'm like oh i
had so much energy i was up at 4 am and
i drank coffee and i worked out and i
was like this is great
so i decided i'm going to start that i'm
gonna i'm going to get up and start
working out and so
this blogger i follow was talking about
this app
where she looked great she had all this
energy and i was like i need what you
have
so she keeps talking about this dang app
and i was like this is
this is going to solve my problem i just
need this app
well i went to purchase this app and it
said that you get a better deal if you
buy like a year-long membership versus
paying for the app month-to-month
and you know me i like a good deal i saw
saving money and i thought well that's
smart sure why not
so i clicked on it thinking in my head
that i was gonna pay a smaller fee
month to month i did not realize that it
was going to charge me
the whole thing right then so i go about
my day
you know thinking about you know all the
all the workouts that this app that i
bought not knowing that you can have
free apps that give you this information
but i was like i'm gonna be so great and
so happy and so
energized well our itunes bill
came through the email and winston was
like
who spent a hundred and thirty-one
dollars
and nine cents
i thought that's crazy who did
i don't know and i looked
and saw it was that dang app that i
bought and this is in february and i was
like
oh i didn't realize it's gonna charge me
the whole thing it was like
wait it's fine like are you using it
no i wasn't i opened that up about two
times
and i didn't use it guys guys
read the terms of agreements i tried to
cancel the app
no go definitely no go so the app is
still on my phone
haunts me to this day just the
conviction that like
tears through that iphone every time i
open it
man am i still working out
no absolutely not so all things was a
bad cycle
man 131 you guys that's a lot of money
gone because i didn't read the fine
print
small decisions can affect your future
[Music]
moving to a new city by myself and i
really needed someone i could trust
as soon as i talked to jerry i knew i
had found
what i needed in a real estate agent
jerry listened to me
cared about me and found exactly what i
was looking for
it's an honor to tell you about the army
national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at 825-5225
we are celebrating his first ramsey
publication which uh came out today
uh a ramsey quick read which is an
80-page
couple of chapters book a short quick
read
and the book is called redefining
anxiety what it is
what it's not and how to get your life
back if you're one of the many
uh tens of thousands of people who are
thrilled that dr john is on this team
and has something to say
you can be sure and uh get in touch
he'll make sure you
are you can get in touch with the
bookstore and we'll make sure we send
you out one of these in return for a 10
bill that's how this works redefining
anxiety
good stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five weakest is with us in
albany new york hi wikis how are you
hi good thank you so much for taking my
call uh
i've actually just recently been
introduced to your program and i've been
watching your
uh youtube videos online um
my question was i've been thinking about
getting a new car
for about two years now and this is like
my dream car
and i wanted to like every time i tried
to buy it and
i hold off thinking that i should save a
bit more and then
and now i feel like i'm at a point where
i should take the
lead and buy this car and i just wanted
to make sure
i'm doing the right thing if not you
know you feel free to yell at me
i'm not going to yell at you you sound
like a nice young man
i will instruct you firmly he yells at
me weakest
i am not a yeller okay so let's talk
let's talk
first thing is are you paying cash
yes okay that's the first rule of thumb
the second rule is
i'm a boy i love things with wheels and
motors
that go vroom vroom i don't care what it
is
a four-wheeler on the farm the sea doo
in the in the
at the lake house or one of the boats at
the lake house the louder the muffler
the better because i'm a good redneck
right
and so uh
so i'm with you on car purchases the
thing i have learned
is that uh the car
boat sea doo rv
are the largest things that we buy
that go down in value and oh
boy do they go down in value it's
pretty much just like setting hundred
dollar bills on fire when you buy a
vehicle
right yeah and so the the more
of that you do the less money you're
going to have
and so the rule is that we use and i use
it personally as well
that i don't want things with motors or
wheels
or both that added all of them up
equal more than half my annual income
because i have too much going down in
value while i'm trying to go the other
way
okay so what do you make
from my day job no what do you make
what's your household income in a year
uh 85 grand and then from my rental
income
i bring in about 1500 a month
she own a rental house yeah okay
all right so that's another eighteen
thousand is that is that and there's no
payments on that
that's uh after i pay mortgage and uh
taxes okay all right so you got another
18 000 on top of your 85.
so let's call it 100 grand give or take
and
because you could probably got some
expenses on the rental but give or take
now the um car costs
what after taxes and fees about 50 grand
okay so you're right on that bubble of
50
what's the car it's tesla model 3.
i was going to guess okay all right
i have i mean i've saved up for it i
have about 100 grand
in savings as well okay that's right i
don't have any other
any other uh debt no credit card um i
drive a 2007 toyota camry right now
i got you so so here's the thing
here's the thing yeah you can do this
because it fits our guidelines
it's a 50 of your income or less
and you're paying cash okay so if you
want to do it i'm not going to yell at
you you would go ahead
and do it how old are you i'm 32. okay
now but let me tell you this the more
often
that you repeat this decision the less
money you're going to have
and you have done unusually good with
money you have some money
so you're successful financially you're
doing good stuff with money
but just know that the more money we put
in a pile in the front yard and set fire
to it
the less money we're going to have and
that's basically what you do when you
buy a car
so in other words don't do this again in
three years
don't do don't do this again in eight
months okay you know that kind of a
thing right
so don't make a habit of being right on
the bubble
and having 50 because i got to tell you
i got a friend of mine that made 10
million dollars last year what if he put
50
of his income and stuff that went down
in value
that'd be like mathematical suicide and
so
that's in a sense right where you are if
you told me 60 i'd tell you not to buy
it
if you told me 70 i'd say don't buy no
way
so you know you're smart you're wise
in that it is pinching your emotions a
little bit to do this
um you know what you might do i don't
know the model 3 because i don't know
the teslas
but um uh what you might do is
back off and buy a two-year-old for 30.
that would probably be a better way to
scratch the itch
then if you wanted to move up later you
know
you could move up later in into a
another one oh
wait a minute if a model 3 is brand new
i wouldn't do that yeah no because i
don't buy brand new cars that's the 30s
third thing unless you have a million
dollar or greater net worth than you do
not
and going from an 07 camry to a model 2
tesla is going to feel like you landed
on a rocket ship anyway
right you i mean is it two the used one
is that what it is
because he said three i'm just assuming
so okay i don't know
i don't know what they are so i mean if
you if you ask me about a
pickup truck i probably tell you but
okay so anyway
yeah you it br if it's brand new that's
the other thing i take it off the table
that's the other part and not because
it's tesla just because there's anything
because the largest loss in value
is a brand new car right you're gonna
lose because this thing's going to lose
60 to 70 percent of its value in the
first four years that's the average new
car and i have no idea what teslas do
but they are pretty much like anything
um
and you know yeah anyway
so it's uh um early in the days i'm
telling people not to buy teslas because
you might end up with a delorean
oh gotcha cause we know if he's gonna go
broke or not yeah apparently he's musk
is gonna pull this out
he's hanging on the fourth quarter but
he's making it so uh i'm not going
to give him a hard time but uh but uh
yeah that that's
so i don't buy experimental stuff right
you know the first year
of a brand new car company is not what i
don't i don't need i waited a few years
to get a
to get a vcr right i wanted to be i
might delorean
now that would be cool man to have the
back to the future delorean that'd be
that'd be neat wasn't it and they were
there what they're like stainless steel
right
they weighed like 9 million pounds yeah
but they could run on gigawatts
well they're so cool there's that yeah
uh so yeah
if it's brand new we just we're gonna
take that off the table
uh but that's the whole discussion but i
use tesla
it's a good it's a if that's what it was
it might have been you i didn't ask him
that before i let him go
but um it's a great discussion
because car payments listen if you're
sitting with two car payments and you
keep two car payments
you are making a statement and putting
it on the wall
in needlepoint i want to be middle class
my whole life
hmm because car payments that says
you're buying new cars
and and you got payments all the time
and you're paying payments on things
that are going down in value
and you 100 mathematically are
destroying
your largest wealth building tool which
is your income
and so you're just you're just making
that statement you didn't mean to
but it's like needlepoint grandma used
to do oh yeah
framed right there i want to be middle
class my whole life that's why i have
two car payments
and so now if you want to be wealthy you
buy
you drive the camera drive the camera
until you're ultra wealthy yeah that's
it
interesting discussion this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
i started my first business when i was
16 years old
i didn't like breakfast foods and the
protein bars that were out there
in 1990 there weren't many choices and
so i created
one to get the protein that i needed
i created this recipe in one night and
when i did it i was doing it just for
myself
i didn't plan to start a business but it
went from the idea to create the product
to making this recipe and then realizing
how delicious it was and i wanted to
share it with others
and so the next morning i made extra and
i packed them in a picnic basket
walked around to businesses and tried to
sell my product
so it went from like having an idea to
an actual product to my first sale in 24
hours
and after that i was hooked i was like i
really want to keep doing this
[Music]
this journey has happened over 28 years
there were so many times that i wanted
to quit in the beginning
in the nutrition field can be a very
daunting field to get into when you
really don't know what you're doing
i had a product that i had created this
protein snack bar
and i had it evaluated by a nutritionist
and i got the nutrition facts
but so many people in that field were
questioning me about it then there was
an area
like marketing and pricing so many
people would challenge me because i
didn't have
experience in those fields but rather
than
stopping rather than being fearful what
i would do is i would say
yes i don't know about this i don't know
that much about marketing i don't know
anything about how to price my product
for retail
can you help me what would you do and so
i would learn from their experience
that's really hard at 16 17 years old to
go
into a complete stranger into a store
and ask who is the person that i need to
speak to
tell them about your product tell them
what the price is and ask them well you
sell my product for me
that forced me to interact with people
[Music]
at a one-to-one a face-to-face level
and that's so important that's a lot of
what i believe in today
[Music]
being able to be who i am from the time
i wake up to the time i go to bed
that to me is the most rewarding i don't
have to change
who i am to be successful i don't have
to be
a hard or bossy person i can't imagine
doing anything else when starting a
business you're going to have
challenges it's going to be hard it's
going to be difficult don't stop
don't give up really believe in what
you're doing there's just something
magical
about being able to guide your own path
for anyone who's thinking about starting
their own business
you know if you're that person stay true
to your path
and what you believe in what you want to
do
[Music]
hello hey guys we're here at blake
thompson's house and we're supposed to
shoot this video about saving money on
your electric bill but it uh
doesn't look like he's home but we're
not about to pack up waste all that gas
and drive back out here later
we're going to conserve that energy and
do this thing anyway
[Music]
guess you don't need to lock your doors
around here and you know what they say
when the cat's away the mice will play
let's do this
turning your thermostat down 10 or 15
degrees for eight hours a day would
shave 15
off your bill smart thermostats make it
easy to set it and forget it
your water heater is probably set way
higher than it needs to be
turn that bad boy down to 120 degrees
and watch that bill drop
lighting takes up 25 percent of your
energy bill but led bulbs use 90
less energy and last up to 25 times
longer replace five bulbs and you could
save up to 75 bucks a year
up to 90 of your washing machines energy
goes to heating the water
skip the hot cycle and wash everything
on cold with a cold water detergent
your refrigerator is the only appliance
in the house that runs 24
7. save money by keeping the fridge temp
between 36 and 38
and the freezer between zero and five
even when your electronics are turned
off they're using phantom energy which
can amount to 15
of your build plug all those gadgets
into power strips for one tap shut off
like a box george what are you doing
here
and there's your minute money hack get
out
hey if you enjoyed this video we've got
a whole minute money hack playlist
waiting for you right here on our
youtube channel and if you've got some
energy saving tips we want to hear them
leave them in the comments below you're
financially conscious
you know that health care expenses can
take a big bite out of your budget
christian health care ministries or chm
is here to help
trim those expenses and make sure your
family is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 thousand dollars
worth of bills
and got close to 75 discounts chm
shared the rest of the expenses to see
if chm is right for you and your budget
check out chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions jake
and carrie are with us on the debt-free
stage hey guys how are you
good how are you welcome welcome where
do you guys live uh mascuta illinois so
right outside of st louis
st louis folk welcome to nashville good
to have you
and all the way down here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
uh 90 838 very good and how long did
that take
two years and seven months all right
very good
in your range of income during that time
uh we started out at 75 000 and
up to 120 now very good what do you guys
do for a living
i'm a dental hygienist and i'm an
estimator for a construction company
very good very good so your income shot
way up really
over the last two years very good
excellent what do you attribute that to
uh we both just kind of found out we
were underpaid and took new jobs same
field and
jumped our income up yeah once you start
trying to get out of debt you're looking
for money and you're going i think i
need more money
yeah that's a good thing wow you were
almost underpaid by half
yeah i took a big pay bump when i moved
companies
wow that's pretty impressive for you
guys yeah well done
all right what kind of debt was the 91
thousand dollars
uh just uh like 1800 bucks on a credit
card
like 23 on a car and uh we found out
like 500 bucks on some medical that was
in collections we had no idea about
halfway through
and then all the rest of student loans
bunch of student loan debt
okay 23 000 on a car no 2 300
2 300 you had a bunch of student loans
yeah yes wow
so we're talking like 80 grand worth
yeah yeah okay oh my goodness
very cool all right so what happened two
months and
two years and seven months ago that got
this started so start a little before
that my brother-in-law who's here
unexpectedly lost his job uh and they
started going through fpu and telling us
about it and so we kind of
us and my mom my parents jumped on the
on the bandwagon and
uh today we're all debt-free wow
happened to be a job loss that got
everyone going it's a family affair
i love it i love it wow very cool so
uh he gets it started because he's
freaking out losing his job
and you guys jump into the class just
kind of okay well let's check this out
yep and went through financial peace
university all right
very neat so okay so you kind of wander
in i mean you didn't have
it was like well check it out sounds
like right is that yeah
we had separate accounts and i was
stressed because i paid all the bills
and we
cheated all we did i mean married
so you pretty much just kind of stumbled
into this thing because of the
brother-in-law and then
you go to that first class or second
class or third class when did it click
and you went oh my god we got to do this
honestly before i started watching your
show as soon as i heard about it
i'm telling her everything and i did it
did the wrong approach where i'm like
you know we're selling everything and
doing it and she's like whoa
no we're not so uh we went to the class
and kind of got on the same page started
budgeting
uh we were paying over 1500 a month in
student loan payments oh my gosh
so yeah she she's a dental hygienist her
bull crapo meter is pretty high right
yeah how many people a week tell you
that they floss and they're like
right so she's got you man she knows
yes so he comes to you and says we're
supposed to drive
two professions in the world he's the
dental hygienist
that's right followed by the person at
the at the
airline counter as to why we're changing
our tickets right so
so he comes to you and says i'm gonna
sell everything what's your response
i definitely was nervous about it first
i wasn't
yeah and i didn't i wasn't for it at
first i'll be honest so
and i don't think i really was into it
and believing it until we were really
starting to see things paid off yeah i
think what i
said i'm going to sell my motorcycle to
get it going i think that's when she was
probably like okay he's pretty serious
yeah as opposed to selling her car
which we didn't have much cars to sell
anyway so yeah okay
all right wow guys very cool so
uh when people ask and you know your
whole family's gotten out of debt
your parents or brother-in-law the whole
bit um
and they ask what's the key because
you've observed it with your family
you've also lived it
you're experts now on getting out of
debt
so people want to know in america how do
you get out of debt what are the keys
uh i would just i would say one of the
things is dedication and you got to stay
motivated
it's really hard the first when you
first start you're fired up you're
paying off all these little ones
but when you get three quarters away
through and you're trying to pay off a
twelve thousand dollar debt it's just
taking months and months
it's dragging on uh i led
fpu a couple times um so that was
helpful
yeah our whole family going through it
leading it makes you do it even more
than going through it
yeah yeah so i feel like people hearing
like
or hearing people doubt you helps you
too oh
yeah a lot of our friends doubted us so
yeah i'll show you
so now you now you get to say you know
how you like me now right
yeah have a little toby keith moment we
want you to call out every one of your
haters right now
just kidding give us their names right
now their cell numbers that's right
that's right
it's like going back to the mean girl in
high school here oh my gosh
wow well it is motivating people tell
you can't do something
it will mean especially once you've
decided you're going to you're like i'll
show you
yeah that's good this is very good yeah
there's a guy in the radio business that
wrote a real nasty letter one time about
how the dave ramsey show wasn't going to
be worth anything never mount anything
and we framed it and put it on the wall
in the radio area
just to fuel us just piss me off like
a decade worth of pissed off yeah i mean
yeah he's not in the business anymore
either by the way
so uh and we are but yeah i mean that's
just yeah
come on bring it yeah that i agree with
you not that dave hangs onto things or
anything like that right
i don't have any issues with grudges no
dave if you don't know is actually uh
latin for the word grudge
guys way to go we're so so very proud of
you
so you guys were cheering each other on
you had people on fpu cheering you on
you were cheering them on there's a lot
a lot of positive around you too
right yeah we uh just to say that
within the last three years our whole
family my parents paid off their house
their
people uh we've paid off in the last
less than three years 300
over almost 330 thousand dollars between
three families yeah yeah there we go
i like a family total that's good and
very good has this bro
together yeah you brought them with you
right yeah they're over here
holding on to the grandbaby which is
really hard work
yeah how old is your baby he's eight
weeks eight weeks
we had two things we wanted to do we
needed to get a newer car because we had
a two-door car and one without air
conditioning so we saved up during covid
actually and i know you told you tell
people to pause but we just wanted to
get it done
and so we bought a uh 14 000 suv cash we
stayed up for
wow and then um we wanted to have that
and be debt-free before he was born so
he didn't have to ever live with that
there you go wow he won't his your
family tree
is changed and your dad's family tree's
changed i mean that's that's
this is very cool generational we're
looking at right here three generations
very very cool way to go guys
i love it well we got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires of course that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
you are on the way 120 000 income
now and having paid off 91 000 over two
years
and seven months oh they're gonna bring
this little baby over oh we're gonna
scream with the baby with the special
headphones oh he's got the headphones on
that's good
that way we don't scare him and wake him
up yeah
we've had some parents that just blew
their kids here
a little too excited oh he's cute very
fun
very fun if they stayed a little out i
had 10 they they kept growing up wanting
cars and tuition but um
yeah way to go you guys very well done
all right here it is
jake and carrie and braden from st louis
area 91
000 paid off in two years and seven
months making 75 to 120.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three three two one where'd that free
braden never flinched not even a little
bit he's just still sleeping
i love it that's so cool man that is
awesome look at it there's three
generations out there man that's so neat
so neat and a few tears too that's so
cool man
every time it's cool i mean wow when you
can change something like that they uh
that's breathtaking it is so next time
you lose your job
just go ahead and get your brother and
sister-in-law out of debt
your mom and dad mom and dad out of debt
and yourself out of that
so that's turning the negative into a
positive how's that for all things that
work together i love it man
that's fun stuff this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so when winston and i got married i'll
never forget it we had been married
probably a few months
and i knew we should be budgeting like
when you get married like that was
grilled into my mind growing up i mean
if i heard my parents say this once i
heard them say it a thousand times
like when you get married you have to be
on the same page you have to budget
together
i mean i even remember our pre-marital
counselor sat down with us in one of our
sessions she was like you all should do
a mock budget
together i was like did my dad pay you
to tell us
like everyone told us and i knew it
again but just doing it i was like eh
i don't really want to and so once that
i've been married about
it was like four or five months and we
hadn't done a budget
and remember one day he was like rachel
we're in our condo in knoxville
tennessee
and he was like rachel we need we need
to do a budget like we've got to figure
out where all of our money's going
and i was like oh you're one of those
aren't you
i thought okay i know we need to but i
don't want to but let's do it let's do
it so i remember we sat down with a
yellow pad on this old dining room table
it was like a hand-me-down table
and we did our first budget and i'll
tell you guys it was a
disaster like you would think i don't
know the cost of food or something
because i think i budgeted like fifty
dollars
for food that month which obviously is
not a reality
and i was like oh gosh it was just bad
like nothing worked like all of our
numbers were off it was terrible
and so the second month we're like okay
we can do a little bit better now we
kind of know okay let's do it
the second month got a little better
there were still things we had to change
the third month honestly was working
there was like two or three things to
change then
and by the fourth month it was like
clockwork it
started working and so for you guys
trust me
give yourself 90 days for those of you
that have never budgeted before or
you've tried the budget and then you
quit because it didn't work the first
month
you need to stick with it give yourself
90 days and download every dollar
it's our free budgeting app and it is
amazing it's all right there and it's so
easy but i promise this is the fastest
way
that you're going to have a great
financial turnaround in fact people that
do zero based budgeting which is what we
teach and that's what every dollar set
up for
they pay off 53 more debt
than people that don't do zero-based
budgeting and they save
five percent more so make sure that
you're doing this and being purposeful
it's the quickest way you're gonna save
money at home
i promise
i call my show all the time complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people out
of their time shares we have we kind of
helped create this industry
now there's a lot of exit companies out
there they come and they go
times sure extra team is different i
mean we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
our guarantee is that if we can't get
you out of your timeshare we give you
your money back
hey if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 5 16 in
the same way let your light shine before
others so that they may see your good
works
and give glory to your father who is in
heaven
alex trebek passed away unbelievable man
he said don't tell me what you believe
in i'll observe how you behave
and i will make my own determination
that's it that's it
there you go i think i may have told you
i was working doing an internship with a
child psychologist and i
was was had a young son at the time and
i was
um double dipping where i would ask
quote unquote questions about clients
but i was really asking
parenting questions i'll never forget
when i asked him hey man
how are you supposed to what are you
supposed to say to a young little boy to
help him respect women in the
appropriate way
and he looked at me and kind of smiled
and said you say whatever you want man
but he's just going to watch how you
treat your wife
and if you want to teach your son how to
respect women then treat your wife right
and they just walked into the next room
and that phrase they don't listen to you
they watch you just stuck with me right
rachel always says more is caught than
talk that's right yeah
yeah so uh you know they were talking
about
uh financial peace university all three
of those family sets and that last debt
free screen went through it
financial peace university is one of the
things
that you get to go through when you are
a member
of the all access membership at ramsey
plus
ramsey plus is a year-long membership
and it has the best money tools
and content everything is there
financial peace university which
actually works
every dollar the premium version is
there the baby steps tracker
there are groups there that you can
participate in you can go to a local
class if it's if there's a physical one
being held
in your area some of them are some of
them aren't uh there are tens of
thousands of virtual classes going on
right now
uh you can get into uh and there is no
reason for you to not have the impact
that that last
couple and that whole family had over
six million
families people have gone through
financial peace university
it is the class on how to handle money
and it is included in
your ramsey plus membership where you
get all the tools
all the support the coaches are in there
everything's there
to make sure that you can do the stuff
that we talk about here
every day on the air can you white
knuckle it and do it by yourself
sure but why not put the world's best
tools at your fingertips to make it
as easy as possible it's a mo it's a
difficult journey at best
it's very hard to do this stuff but you
can do it
so oh by the way since it's all digital
you can download the workbook even
everything's there right you can skip
all the chaos
it makes a great christmas giveaway so
just go to daveramsey.com
store ramsey plus and uh if you want to
give it as a gift if you want to
just jump in and start doing it you can
get a free trial
as well and just check it out see how it
works for you
uh you can get started anyway and uh
just go to daveramsey.com
store get in the store and you can pick
that up while you're there you can pick
up john delony's new book redefining
anxiety what it is what it's not and how
to get your life back
anxiety a top of mind
concept a top of mind subject these days
especially in the year
known as anxiety when you look 2020 up
it is the numbers that mean
anxiety but um that's the ancient greek
20 20. it's the uh numerology that's
right when you
yeah that's uh hey dave i don't know if
i'm allowed to plug it this way
but i'm going to my wife and i use that
every dollar app
wow so it's not just something why would
you not be allowed to do that
well i i i sometimes i just think it's
important that
some of these things aren't just pitches
these are aren't just
things that we put out into the
marketplace but these are things that we
use behind closed doors too
yeah and that has helped i actually told
our team this morning
yeah and make sure you're going through
financial peace university and if you
don't get a will
i'm and you die i'm going to kill you
that's exactly right david dave
announced to the company if you don't
get a will
and you die i'm going to kill you that's
we furnish a will as a
employee benefit that's right you know
through the mama bear stuff that's all
that
right so and then they don't go get one
it's free i'm gonna kill them
[Music]
but this app my wife and i use it it
helps us communicate it helps us talk
helps us to stay accountable
it's a good thing man i i appreciate it
it's not something we just up here
throwing out into the wind trying to
sell we use it we use this stuff too and
it's it's legit and i'm an almost
app-free guy
like i don't i like a pen and a paper
and this thing's great man
yeah oh absolutely well it is the
world's best i mean our guys the
the technology team that we've got on it
it's so uh robust i mean it does
everything yep and uh it's easy to use
so
and it's included you know the premium
version that connects to your bank is
included when you're in ramsey plus it
all ties together
i mean you can go over and just do every
dollar if you want to do that or you can
go over here and just do this or just do
that
it's all together you can get a yellow
pad and do it i mean you can do a budget
with yellow pad
you can you can live on less than you
make you'll be all right you know you're
going to work it out
it's just a matter which is the most
efficient thing in the process that
we've
we've been doing this for 30 years so
we've toned it in and knocked the rough
edges off and it's the
it's the you know the least heavy
lifting of a very heavy lift
to completely change your life so again
ramsayplus
at daveramsey.com just click and date
click into the store
justin's with us in arkansas or in
arizona i'm sorry glendale to be exact
hi justin how are you
i'm doing all right dave how are you
doing better than i deserve how can i
help
awesome well uh first i want to thank
you guys for taking the call i
appreciate that a lot actually
um so i'll try to keep things as short
as i can my fiance and i
we recently had a baby six months ago
and we've been renting a home
from her uncle and uh recently her uncle
came and told us that
because it's a seller's market right now
he wants to sell the home
so he believes that when i guess when
trump's out of office there's going to
be a crash i guess
so he told us we have until he's out of
office to kind of get out
um and right now i'm unable to work
because of a workplace injury
a little over a year and a half ago and
the pandemic
pushed my fiance out of work you know
two days before giving birth to our
daughter
uh so we have no verifiable like income
to actually prove we
you know have finances and due to really
poor choices and both of our adolescent
uh our scores are in the low 500s for
his credit
and we've been trying to find places to
rent we've even offered
a year's rent up front and we've still
been being turned down
so you have the money with all that yes
uh currently we have
34 000 saved okay because we were
we were trying to fix our debt issues
with a lot of your methods that we had
seen and that's how we were saving money
prior to
us both losing our jobs yeah how old are
you two
i'm 28 and she's 27. what's the nature
of your workplace injury
it's a neurological issue i uh
i was a semi truck driver and i was
lifting some rebar
and it popped something in my back and
due to that
i ended up getting diagnosed with
peripheral sensory and axial neuropathy
so i have constant uh nerve pain in my
feet and hands and back
so it's like electrical zaps burning
um throbbing and then swelling what is
your what is your long-term plan with
all of that because that sounds
very painful what's your long-term plan
for your income to provide for your
child
uh right now the doctors told me my best
bet is to apply for disability
which they've been trying to help me do
but it's a very
long process and what did your fiancee
do before she lost her job
she was a uh food and beverage manager
at a hotel
she would like i guess manage the
restaurant and
parts of the hotel and do all the
cooking like she helped with that she
helped me
the good news is that we'll be back and
uh the good news is that you're
with what you're describing you have a
pretty severe disability and so you
would qualify
it'll just take some time to get that
through ssi's difficult you're dealing
with the feds
but um you'll get through what you've
got to do is find a landlord
who will listen to your whole story and
not just look at your credit score
if you told me your story and you showed
me you had thirty four thousand dollars
and you showed me that she has that
she's planning to go back to work as
soon as uh she can find something in the
food and beverage field
uh and you're gonna pre-pay for one year
i'm probably giving you a shot
if i look at you and you just convey
irresponsibility
all over the place even with 34 000 i'm
not giving you a shot but there are
reasonable
explanations in your life with what's
going on here now are you going to get
this average apartment manager that's 26
years old and works for somebody who's
out of town to do this
no but you're gonna find a landlord that
has a small house somewhere
that you can move into and go do that
so um i'm sorry her uncle's freaking out
but probably better to get out of there
anyway since he's freaking out
that puts us out of the dave ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
you